And doing it again,
I can.
That's my new opening.
Sorry.
Voice.
Yeah.
It's nothing so it doesn't even seem like I'm trying just.
It's just coming out.
It's coming out like that.
You know what it is because you speak the truth.
It's just the truth coming out.
Truth coming out in my angel voice.
I told you,
that's what I go.
How do you sing like that?
You didn't even warm up.
She goes,
what are you talking about?
I go,
you just go eat.
Ate a big dinner,
and you just got up,
sang and she goes,
I don't know.
I just tell the truth and everything else takes care of itself.
But that pitches like the Michael Jordan of soldiery songs know she could sing
the fucking shit out of some music.
Unreal.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by WHO's today?
Oh,
well,
first of all,
on [inaudible] dot com.
That's our main sponsor on it is the supplement slash lifestyle company.
I don't like calling anything a lifestyle company.
We were going to have to come up with a good name for what it is.
It sounds so not Joe Rogan,
so gay and like force,
like sell a lifestyle.
We were talking to this guy who,
uh,
he,
um,
produces podcasts for a friend of ours and we were at the Improv and homeboy
battered us with these industry terms.
Do we,
weren't you there when that conversation was like,
you guys done a really good job of projecting you're exactly where you're
talking about.
It's really,
really good job of predicting,
projecting your brand.
I was like,
what the F I want to kill you.
I'm going to kill you if you don't get away from me talking to this fucking
joke.
You.
I'm not thinking about a brand.
I'm thinking about doing something good.
You're a goddamn vampire,
sir.
You don't even know.
Let's be honest.
No.
What'd you say that when you say branding a brand that takes away the purity of
the intention,
right?
Let's be honest.
It's the onnit call is what you'd call it.
Well,
I don't even want to call it the.
I don't want to name it,
but you know what it is.
But listen man,
I'm not,
I'm not.
I'm not susceptible to call the stuff and everything you sell.
I'm like,
I want those chimps.
I'm 45.
I'm like,
I,
oh sorry.
I can't say,
but I just want those and then I want the jerky and all stuff I use.
Well,
you know,
there's like,
there's a lack of a celebration of a fucking exciting manly shit in this
country.
Of course is.
There's a big suppression of it and we add on it or a against that whole
heartedly and we think it'll take supplements if we had stuff that makes your
dick hard.
We're going to look into that.
We got some hard dick natural supplements.
W will get you those.
We'll,
we'll find out there any good.
We'll run some tests and we'll get you.
The data exists,
but the stuff that we have,
everything that we have is shit that we use.
We use the best quality ingredients.
We put together the best possible combination of these things,
whether it's for Alpha brain or knew mood,
knew mood is a fascinating one because you know there's a lot of people in this
country that are on stimulant or well,
there's a lot of people that are on stimulants where there's a lot of people
that are on Ssri antidepressants.
They're on things that essentially stimulate serotonin in your mind or or add it
to your brain,
you know,
you can add it artificially or five htp
and l trip defender.
Two different ways that it boosts your brain's production of Serotonin and five
htp hasn't been as it's been explained to me,
five hcb converts into Serotonin and Tryptophan converts into five htp,
so when you put them together,
it's like a time release thing.
It's just,
it's all.
It's just science about nutrition and what is effective for what aspect of
performance,
whether it's mental performance like Alpha brain or physical performance like
shroom,
tech,
sport.
All of it is described on it.
We describe why we're selling.
This is what it is.
This is why.
How we got involved in it.
This is,
these are the people that tell you it's good and we're dealing with professional
poker players.
A lot of pro athletes love all the different products because they,
they're just,
it's,
we're just trying to find the most effective shit out there.
What's the best shit?
Let's sell it.
We were talking about Kale shakes.
I make Kale shakes almost every morning and I haven't all week though,
a three days in a row and I do feel the difference.
Feel like a fat fuck today.
Your skin is positive and glowing.
A lot of water.
Um,
so we decided to get BLENDTEC blenders.
We found those are the best we're selling as we sell them $200 less than the
manufacturer suggested retail price.
Just because we're trying to sell you the best shot possible at the lowest price
possible.
That that is the number one goal with on it.
And everything we sell you is shit.
We use metal belt.
No scarves.
I'm against old dudes with scarves.
And I think Randy coture,
feminist scholar,
but he's been wearing a scarf lately and I just want to talk to randy couture
was such a bad motherfucker.
Turn it around his neck.
Who Cares?
Ballet could be in a leotard and I'd still be like,
stay away from me.
He could go out to clubs with a real legitimate albatross around his neck and
you wouldn't care.
Speaking of which,
did you see Matt Makani in magic?
Mike?
No,
I missed that.
I never met anybody wanting to have sex to themselves more.
That guy.
Oh God.
I mean he.
I guarantee you.
Jerks.
Officers,
highlight reel.
He.
He basically has just stock footage of him stretching his character or Matt
mcconaughey.
Hey,
the human factors.
It's like,
why don't you take that role,
take that role.
You took that role so you could wear outfits and go and go.
That's what he does.
And I've never seen anyone.
Now I have to go through it.
It's a bigger why commercials with.
Sorry,
sorry.
Sorry.
Because I need to know about this because I saw the ad for that.
I got a little panicky.
Oh No,
we ads.
We're so gay that I was like,
what's going on here?
What is this?
Tatum o'neal or whatever the guy's name is.
He couldn't look better.
Handsomest guy.
I hung out with him in Vegas for a weekend.
Women literally start just operating in his presence and he's a great guy.
They must panic.
He said he was an athlete going on with the sound.
Brian.
That sound like a pool.
When he's talking,
it's getting really loud or screaming into a microphone.
Probably not.
It's normal.
I'm using my stage voice now.
Mine is down.
I want to talk about chapter two.
Dance
therapy.
Screaming in the voice.
It's not going to pop the minute,
but it doesn't sound good.
This.
It's very gay.
The easiest thing.
Well,
something's wrong.
I'm not hearing myself.
You're not hearing.
You're not like a like a little.
There you go guys.
If you screw up,
just get your microphone technique.
I start talking about channing tatum and my voice was like,
but it shouldn't crack that easy.
Brian.
This is like some little crackle when it gets high here.
That.
Yeah,
because you're screaming into a microphone.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're on stage,
it happens.
You just can't hear it because it's a big stage,
but when you're in a recording studio,
you're screaming in a microphone.
You're going to.
Don't say,
this is a new thing.
Here's what we could do.
We could turn it down like this.
You could turn your headphones up right now and it'll be really quiet.
You're just not going to pop the mic.
All right.
Just try,
try turning one of these knobs right here.
Track check.
I like Tacos.
Highlight Tacos.
Going to be in Columbus,
Ohio this week.
Or in Ohio.
If you want to go to a show,
go to a desk while TV.
You're going to be with Tom Segura.
Doug Benson.
Uh,
yeah.
We got a Dayton,
Ohio on the eighth,
which is Thursday,
Cincinnati on Friday,
and then Saturday we have a Columbus,
Ohio.
And if you use the coupon code in Cincinnati,
Red Cross,
you get two for one tickets.
Also 10 percent of the portion of the ticket sales goes to hurricane relief for
Indiana.
And
why keep making upstairs and you can get hit by hurricanes.
You son of a bitch.
That sound better.
Much better.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the microphone cord.
That's what it was that the,
um,
the headphone Jack was really,
really low.
I'm honored.
Uh,
you know,
we,
we started carrying things like kettle bells and battle ropes and we're going to
continue to supply the craziest fitness shit we can get our hands on.
What probably club bells when moving to those next.
Those are pretty bad ass.
We use those.
I just started doing those.
You know,
you do those,
that shield casting over the shoulders.
Fantastic for the wrists and the forearms and great for functional strength.
So what we'll probably get involved in club bells eventually to all the stuff we
use.
Those stuff that would improve your,
your,
your strength and your conditioning if you doing like Jujitsu or any kind of
athletics.
It's all just about a shit for functional strength.
If you use the code name Rogan,
you will save 10 percent off any and all supplements,
including camp force.
We have hemp force protein powder that's made out of raw hemp,
which by the way,
you can't grow in America.
Ha.
You can buy it from Colorado,
mate,
make marijuana legal this week.
They did that might today.
It's right.
The polls show that the federal government coming to notify that.
Yeah.
Again,
have those concepts,
but you can't.
We,
we,
we sell hamp.
This hemp protein powder does not make you test positive for marijuana.
It's completely non psychoactive.
It's just a related to it or the male of the plan or whatever.
Um,
and um,
we have to buy it from Canada.
We can't grow it here.
It's fucking so ridiculous.
I guess because people would just grow.
We'd go to it.
I totally thought I was going home.
I didn't even know.
Did you hear,
I heard somebody already told me last night that somebody from Israel found out
the way a way to take out like the highness out of marijuana.
So you're just getting the CBDS.
What a jerk.
That rarely Jewish.
Why would,
why would it,
why?
Like I'm just,
Hey,
I want to make.
We're not as fun.
Instead of doing cancer research,
I'm just gonna ruin everybody's fucking life.
Well,
the idea,
Brian,
is it.
Some people just want to be healed from cancer,
they don't want to get high,
so you're like,
you'll be getting high is more important than your cancer.
Silly,
but that's not true.
For some people.
They don't want to get the paranoia.
They just want to cure their diseases.
Combined.
Combined,
it combats nausea and lowers interocular pressure while coma.
That's why glaucoma patients ticket,
is that right?
Anyway,
that Hampshire,
we've got to get it from Canada.
It's not cheap,
but if you buy a Blendtec blender,
you get a free one.
Boom.
Codename Rogan saves you 10 percent off any and all supplements.
This weekend.
Balboa theater,
Joey Diaz and me,
that is this Saturday night.
Fucking very fired up about that.
I can't wait.
San Diego's shit.
I will be able to tell him this weekend,
Friday,
Portland really?
You can get your tickets at helium comedy club,
that fucking club crackles clubs ever.
If you're in Philly,
come see me.
Helium,
philly.
Philly is one of the greatest cities ever because it's the perfect combination
of smart people who will fucking punch you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's always a palpable aggression in the air.
Yeah,
that's very Boston.
Like every was a football player like Michael Irvin.
I go,
what?
What were the worst fans?
Philly,
philly.
He hurt his neck in Philly.
They booed him.
They're like,
Beau.
Usually they clapped and I gotta get off.
Do you remember that?
If I can start the commercial,
Brian,
stop it.
Stopped the commercial over.
Start the podcast.
We're going to just do it.
There's nothing else to talk about.
Death Squad dot TV.
Go Get yourself a kitty cat tee shirt.
You're Fox experience.
We always do this.
Do we have these conversations?
And they go from,
I have a just a shitty.
I'm married to this method of doing commercials.
Like,
yeah,
well sometimes it's okay,
but other times I'm like,
wait,
this is 20 minutes of a commercial that we're not always.
It's
conversations to.
Yeah.
It would be nice if I could figure out how short net,
but the problem is then it weaves itself into conversations that would make like
great podcasts.
We should just do commercials in the middle of the podcast.
Yeah,
I think it's great the way you do it.
Does anybody else do?
Most guys,
they stop and read it in the middle of their podcasts.
I just people doing it.
I like the way you do it,
which is organically get into it and the problem is sometimes it goes into other
conversations.
You don't want it to be a part of the commercial.
Here's what I liked that you believe in every product you endorsed.
Well that's where we're lucky as shit.
Not like an advertisement is what I mean.
The only things that we're we're being advertised by right now is all like,
like ting,
which was an awesome company.
No contracts the way we went with them because they're like,
they use sprints,
backbone,
so they have like really good service,
but you can just cancel.
You couldn't make joint accounts like you and I could share an account which
share minutes.
If you don't use your minutes,
like say if you use like what a lower priced thing would be instead of what you
paid for.
Well then you get discounted on your next bill.
It's like they are like super ethical and fair,
so that's why we went with them.
But when you,
when you're involved in a wow,
like the podcast is weird enough as it is,
so it's like big companies probably wouldn't want to get involved with it.
So it allows you to choose from people that are like taking chances like the
ting people or the people or.
I think what's really unique about it is the fact that you can,
you can pinpoint exactly who your niche audiences if you're talking to very
specific people that are gonna that are interested in it.
Yeah.
Well you know,
and it,
it,
it changes that audience a little bit too as they see the excitement and other
shit.
I mean,
one of the cool things about hovering cool friends is that you get to find out
about cool things and they're into that.
Maybe you didn't know.
When you talk to somebody,
like if you say like if you did not talk,
if you never knew about Jujitsu and you were hanging out with Eddie Bravo and
then you just,
you really had no idea and you're talking to this guy and then all of a sudden
he starts telling you about Jujitsu and when it's like you'd be like,
there's a whole thing I didn't even know about.
That's awesome.
Holy Shit like it.
It invigorates you and fires you up.
You know?
I think that's the biggest thing is like the one of the problems with staying in
one place your whole life is you limit your exposure to,
to everything.
Nowadays though,
the good news is you can be in one place and expose yourself to everything if
you know where to look.
You know?
That never used to be the case.
The world is so much different now than when we were like getting out of high
school.
It's so.
I mean it's not even.
It's like we were living in the dark age.
It really is because you're constantly exposed a little bit.
Like if you look at how wrestling was be in the eighties and then when the wall
came down in the eastern Europeans,
the Russians and they came over and shared all their secrets.
Wrestling even at that high school level was so completely different.
A lot of ways than it was way back.
I mean,
as in certain things just didn't work or they had answers to so many different
things and wrestling technique and for that matter,
look at Jujitsu as everybody starts experimenting and stuff and there's direct
access to it.
Things grow exponentially.
They get,
they seem to,
um,
become more,
uh,
exponentially complex.
I don't know,
it makes our life better,
but I think it does well.
I just think it's unavoidable.
Just seems to be that's the way it just goes with everything.
And there's great from the past and all endeavors,
but it standup comedy in fighting.
I don't think anybody from the past truly holds up.
I know if I look at like a Joe Lewis,
and I imagine what would happen if Joe Lewis had a flight?
Vladimir Klitschko,
I'd be like,
Jesus,
that's not.
Even though he's Klitschkos barely a human right,
and he's totally new species of humans,
right?
Six foot seven,
250 pounds of shredded muscle.
Who's got a doctorate maybe to,
you know,
like smart as shit.
Overachiever,
man.
Just completely boxing your face in,
you know,
it doesn't take any stupid chances.
Just keeps fucking punching you in the face and you can't punch him.
Good Luck Joe.
Get out there and do it for America.
He's a Nazi.
That Klitschko.
Go get them.
Joe Lewis.
Joe Lewis will get fucked up,
dude.
The only guy.
I think there's a few guys like Ali of course would have been great in error.
Any error,
but I always said that.
Put it Mike Tyson against Ali.
Mike Tyson would have stormed them.
Well yeah,
but what he said is this,
Ali said boxing.
People will say,
yeah,
Tyson would have gotten,
would a storm to maybe the first time because he's so powerful.
And guess what?
When they fought the second time,
Ali would have figured them out that maybe,
maybe,
maybe the way by the way he'd be.
Remember Ali took,
it was 220 pounds,
right?
Which is a big man without lifting a big man.
Oh,
and by the way,
he also fought I think nine rounds against frazier with a broken jaw.
The dude could take punish.
That was Ken Norton.
I'm sorry.
But if you watch,
if you watch what frazier didn't,
those amazing fights.
Yeah.
And,
and the hooks and just landing in his face and he just kept fighting and he took
into such incredible punishment and I think his ability to kind of rope and,
and move with shots with a huge part of it for sure.
Smarter than anybody and got into your head,
you know,
look what he did to Sonny Liston.
He realized something listened was the strongest man in the world.
They said the one thing sending listens,
afraid of is a crazy person.
Sonny's afraid of gravel,
crazy person.
And when,
when he did that weigh in,
sunny actually said,
keep them away from me.
I think he's going to bite me.
He was afraid he was going to get bit.
I just think skill wise,
I think Ali was great,
but if you look at the Ali from like the Joe Frazier fight on,
if you compare that guy to Tyson when he was against like say Michael spinks
when he was just the ultimate destroyer,
he was just too.
He was too blindingly fast and a really good box,
unbelievably fast.
That was the thing that people missed and the whole thing and they were like his
power.
Of course he had great power,
but it was the way he delivered it.
He delivered it like half as fast,
like really?
Like he was twice as fast as like the Tony tubs is of the world of the Pink
Lynn.
Tom.
He fought,
raised her run.
I can raise a Ruckus is the biggest,
strongest looking man.
Dude,
man.
He was hitting him in the forehead with,
with hooks and sending him like,
like for sitting down in the air,
like fool now now run a got back up.
But finding the ref was like,
I'm stopping this because somebody's going to lose their brain.
Yeah.
He was like a few years where he was just unbelievably good.
But I think that's the case with basketball.
I think that's the case with baseball.
I think it's the case with all sports that everything just gets better and it's
really fascinating and training techniques,
not just steroids.
Yeah,
that's the big designer drugs when they can jean dope,
you wonder what you're.
You know you're going to have 400 pound Predator nationally athletes,
so then it becomes 100 percent.
It's on the way.
I can't wait.
They're going to keep getting bigger.
Like if you ever met like a real giant pro football player and say I saw a real
law who was really rowdy and he was like at this club in Phoenix,
and it was like a guy who's around a bunch of kids who will just like,
all right,
settle down,
let me throw.
It's exactly how it was.
Almost like a silver back on that.
Boom.
He was gigantic.
The dude was at least 400 pounds and he wasn't fat athletic.
Yeah.
I was like,
I can't believe that's a fucking man.
Rich incognito.
I met at the playboy mansion,
six foot four,
300,
five pounds.
All Blonde.
Silverback,
she belonged to get and literally doesn't even look like he lifts his says
everything is proportioned.
His head,
his shoulders,
his hips.
No.
Who was one of the scariest guys that didn't get his duke.
He came on with the wrong time.
Do you remember Tom Erickson?
Who?
Tom Big Cat Erickson fighter fucking wrestler was 300 pounds now.
Natural.
Gigantic.
No,
no,
that was Paul varlands.
What did they call Tom?
I don't remember what they're called,
but he was a peace dude.
This guy rich on cognitive.
I said,
what are you?
What do you squat?
He goes,
I don't know.
I mean in the eights,
I think a big cats.
That's what it was.
Big Name nickname.
Big Cat.
Because he was a big dude.
He moved like a cat.
That's ridiculous.
He was Tom Erickson,
who was just speaking a big
Russian guy.
I'm the wolf man.
Carolyn.
No,
no,
no.
Forget him.
That guy's legendary.
The last time we lost,
he was 16 years old and then a rulon gardner beat him by based on one of the
mistakes you've made.
I saw the match.
Well,
it's funny.
That was like a new rule when you get a guy to separate their hands.
It's one point when he won the Olympic gold against,
uh,
with the Persian American,
a wrestler who was that who would wrestle him 19 times.
I've never beat him.
And as he was winning the gold,
he had him and he was whispering in his ear,
he was whispering and essentially English saying,
you can never beat me.
It's not possible for you to beat me to saying,
yeah.
So something like that.
And if you see when,
when they are awesome,
when he's,
when he had the silver medal and he did meet and he had a silver medal in the
Olympics and he's up there and somebody gave me,
gave me his name and he's crying.
He's crying because he just realizes that no matter what he did,
no matter how hard he trains,
there is that man named corral and that he will never beat.
He was born.
He was 15 pounds six for 305 pounds.
That's how much you weighed.
He trained
in Siberia.
The fuck is that.
While he was 15 pounds when he was born and he has small parents,
his parents were splitting,
I think his grandfather or someone was a,
was a bear,
you know,
some giant guy.
Carolyn was also me and a very,
very serious competitor.
Like a main competitor would not lose.
No,
no.
And would play games you and talk to you.
And by the way,
you know why he got really why he got really famous and we started hearing about
him is he would suplex people and break their necks.
He'd suplex you and drop you on your neck and that's where people were just so
afraid of him and he was just too strong.
He would get guys.
They would literally completely flattened themselves out on the mat to try to
resist being taken down.
They didn't even try to scramble because if he scrambled and he caught you in
the scramble,
he'd have you elevated and just fucking pile drive you on your head.
It's crazy.
He would pick them up as they were flattening up and he was 300 plus pound men
and from like a lying down 300 pound man to be able to pick him up with a gable
grip and hoist him up in the air.
Most people have no idea how strong you'd have to be so weird.
Like you would have a hard time doing that with a small child.
Like most people would have a hard time,
but he was also very flexible.
He was also like,
he was just a huge mongoose.
Exactly.
He wasn't like a big stupid like power lifter looking due to.
Couldn't move.
No,
he was like a big giant was all back back and traps in relation to his chest.
It wasn't bodybuilder,
his knees and his hips and his.
There's a famous photo of him hoisting a guy up in the air and he's just got
this look of rage and he.
He's so terrible.
It just like embodied those Cold War Olympics where everybody was afraid of the
Russian
champagne.
Shut it down.
He was like the real draco but better.
That's exactly right.
There's a fault.
I got to pull up this photo.
I think our boy,
uh,
um,
Oh God,
the Russian,
the great Russian MMA fighter.
I'm a fit fit or this or he has a little of that,
but he's like a little bit more.
He's not as.
Or is it different?
It's a different thing.
Brian.
Pull.
Pull this up,
pull up Alexander Curl,
pull up Carolyn,
and there's a photo of him with a teacher's going,
oh dude.
It's just is.
I can look at that photo.
See that photo?
That's the one we're looking for.
I see that.
Let me see.
Oh,
I haven't actually seen that one.
K A r e l l I n.
Oh my God.
It's so fucking.
He's got this photo of him.
About to throw this guy for the air.
Look at him and me.
He's the hulk.
Come one 70.
That's the real hulk.
He's like the real hockey.
Doesn't even have a mouthpiece in sending even wearing a mouthpiece as fucking
animal horse.
He's wrestling children.
What are they going to do?
Fat in his live fucking wrestling shoulder.
He's wrestling.
Chill.
We're to be that much better at something and everybody else that's just that
much bigger than.
I mean it's better,
but not much bigger.
Like that guy was ridiculously busy.
Arguably in some ways the toughest,
strongest man in the world.
I mean if you get a photo of it,
it's got to be somebody fucking windows.
Oh,
it crashed.
Why are we still using the
picture?
Who is a terrifying dude?
Who is so God damn.
Yeah.
You went to a guy that have done it.
I should have pinged it.
Look at all these heroin dogs.
Fighting is different to those.
I mean.
Yeah.
Well whenever strikes.
Yeah,
it's a different.
It neutralizes a lot of stuff.
This is not the guy you're looking for.
No,
no,
no.
It's spelled K,
r e l I n his name is Alexander Alexander.
Corella.
Okay.
Yes.
It's awful.
What Bang edits.
Dog Change.
No,
I don't want to bring.
It was just kidding.
I would never do that.
Yeah,
that's the dude.
Go to images
and no one down with him and the tank top gritting his teeth to that.
On that shit man.
What the fuck did at the arms on him?
This was.
Are you kidding?
That is.
So look at that.
Oh,
that's so weird.
It's so scary.
His forearms and his.
Oh,
look at his.
The ferocity and his eyes.
Looking at this joker face joker face.
Craziest thing I've ever seen in my life.
That was the real deal.
Now that is a naked gorilla.
There's a full photo of that too.
Where you get to see his full body.
It's even spookier.
Brian pulled up,
got back to the,
uh,
there's a full photo.
You see his fucking legs go,
scroll up,
scroll up.
Were there.
I would always know that son is always where a single let in that this is an
even better one way is the whole entire body up there.
Then yeah,
that's it.
Click on this.
Look at this shit.
This,
this is big.
This is completely ridiculous.
When you see the actual full image and you get his fucking legs,
look at that.
What the fuck man?
What is he saying?
Lord,
I'm producing estrogens are insane.
That's insane how big his legs guys.
But Dude,
that poor guy is going to a ragdoll mid,
poor that poor guy.
So.
Okay.
So here's the question,
what is he a 100 percent roids like there's something going on there.
I think I would suggest that it's genetic.
If you're born at 15 pounds and if you look at our proportion is body is and the
amount of training he does.
There are people out there that are genetic freaks that don't need steroids.
Yeah.
But you know what?
I bet it is.
I bet it's both because this was Russia.
Russia was not fucking around back then.
That's,
you know,
we had victor content on the podcast and one of the things that he was talking
about is that the elephant in the room when it comes to women's track and field
is that there was a period of time where before they were testing were they
still cannot achieve the results that these eastern bloc women got.
Really?
Yeah.
Like this world records and no one comes close when they win the Olympics every
year.
And he's like,
well,
they just can't.
They can't achieve what these men,
women did.
So because they just a matter of record or it's just what their times,
their ties to the top.
No,
the Times they,
the Times that they had from 10,
20 years ago from whatever it was were they weren't testing with these women
that times were stronger than they are today in the Olympics that they are
behind
the gold metal or behind the world.
Brexit,
no idea about that.
Well,
he said it's 100 percent because they were taking steroids.
He was a fascinating guy to have on because he fucking saw the whole thing
happened from the ground up.
You know,
he saw people like experimenting with all these different supplements and you
know,
he,
he saw and he,
and he's seen track and field athletes like all the sudden get unbelievably
good.
Like within a year.
And everybody was suspicious.
Yeah.
She's a perfect example,
but he's a,
you know,
he's of the opinion that they all do it.
Especially track and field.
He said all those guys are on something.
Yeah.
Well,
the,
you know,
one of the raises the question too,
because they took two of the top fastest guys in the world,
I think it was Justin Gatlin and then Maurice Greene.
I think those are.
And what they found was that he was talking about steroids and he said,
look,
the Maurice Greene naturally has 800 grams or 600 grams of protein,
would not grams a 600,
uh,
whatever that measurement per per gram of blood at 800 you're testosterone at.
Whereas someone like Justin Gatlin has 400,
so naturally occurring,
some people have just more testosterone and usually guys were faster and stuff
stronger.
Well,
we'll then,
what does that say about.
So if that's the case,
is it a fair competition or can this other guy take hormone replacement therapy
and bring his up to $800 right there.
There's where you get into these weird,
weird questions that the,
the argument for steroids,
you can eat foods that increase your testosterone.
So,
so they do it very marginally.
Maybe,
but so where do we draw the line?
Like if the technology exists,
it's,
it's a murky,
it's a murky issue,
right?
It does get murky.
If you want to consider a level playing field,
there is no level playing field because we have ectomorphs,
endomorphs and Meza more's being the body types of ectomorphs are ones who are
really skinny.
You can't gain any weight endomorph,
so the really fat ones have a hard time losing weight or Mesomorphs are those
Wesley Snipes looking dudes?
Just look.
Just ripped and muscular.
You look at Mike Tyson,
classic Mesomorph,
you know,
classically muscular.
Yeah.
That certain people that just Bruno Shapes for Cheick Kongo,
the extreme force,
you,
you know,
you can't.
Some people can never achieve that physical frame.
They just,
they can't naturally.
So what is the what if a pill came along and all of a sudden you turn some dude
who's got
Ralphie may's genetics and all of a sudden
the problem then becomes that competition is all about the best chemist.
I can understand the argument steroids because total now that we all know that
human beings,
if they want to win something,
they'll do everything including sacrifice their own health to get to a point in
time,
but then there's a guy like chlorella and it doesn't matter what the fuck you
do.
It's like there's certain dudes where there's so much of a physical gift.
It's almost impossible for you to overcome it.
There's that.
There's a level,
like the idea is that if a person is super athletic,
that can't be smart as well.
That's not true,
unfortunately.
Unfortunately that guy can fuck you and probably beat you in chess.
Chess,
yeah.
It's just because someone is big and athletic,
like that's a terrifying thing for someone.
Someone who's intellectually dual them and still kick their ass and named Mark
Court told me that GSP is a great chess player,
like a phenomenal chess player.
GSP is an unusual human being.
He's very,
very bright guy.
He's very open and honest.
Like he's one of the rare fighters.
It talks about being scared and you know what went through his head.
Yeah.
He's,
uh,
you know,
like about what makes them insecure and apparently he's got this crazy thing
about aliens.
Oh No.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's uh,
he's terrified about aliens.
I'm finding him in the middle of the night and abducting him,
but there are other things to worry about.
Georgia has a path to get out of his house in case of the len come to my house.
He's got to be kidding.
No,
no.
He really is obsessed with aliens.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's so much so that they filmed a lot of shit and they wouldn't even use it in
the countdown show.
I don't know who didn't like it.
Dana or someone,
you know,
someone made a joke
about it and it tell you about everything.
I think it's ridiculous to not leave it in because I think it's another little
layer and the guy's cake.
The guys that used to look,
he is a bonafide bad motherfucker and anybody who thinks he isn't a bad
motherfucker because he is scared to death.
It's so silly.
He's George fucking cop.
I let him tell his story.
It's probably interesting.
The aliens come from me in the middle of the night,
you know,
I've had my acl repair.
Hey,
I'm.
I hear through the grapevine that Mr Nick Diaz,
who I love,
but my favorite fighter and a lot of ways he wants to fight Mr Anderson Silva.
Yeah,
he'll fight.
Anybody fight fate or he'll fight anybody who doesn't give a fuck.
He's a real fighter sting match.
I think that
Anderson would kick it,
kick him in the face and all that,
but it did.
He's not afraid of his boxing.
I mean he boxes a lot and I.
It seems like he would be a guy who could certainly stand and trade as opposed
to him Damien Maia and and or forest griffin doing with Anderson.
I think that if anybody could actually,
who's a pure boxer who trains with real boxers and is a pretty good boxer,
he might.
He might be able to answer ideas first of all,
takes an unbelievable shot and he could take a hell of a shot.
He's super determined.
No one's got wind.
Liked him.
His endurance is preposterous.
Endurance is completely preposterous.
His,
his endurance is preposterous.
It is flip your swims back from Alcatraz for like a Goof,
so we're getting the ocean and swims from Alcatraz,
like his endurance is freakish and that's one of his,
one of his strengths and everybody's got to be scared of that shit.
But Anderson's never showed endurance problems.
He tapped Chilson in the fifth round of a fight.
He was getting his ass kicked in so he's never had insurance problems.
But I think that Nick Diaz is,
he's a difficult to do to crack.
You know,
like you look at like really good start because like Paul Daley,
Paul Dale is a dangerous fucking strike.
Decided to stand and trade with him.
He's a much better rest.
I haven't standard trade on.
By the way you hit me with a left.
Watch this.
He goes down,
gets up,
Bang with the left will not only that,
such a true fighter and I'm on the ground and nick is so good at wrapping you up
and you have to look after that armbar man.
That shit comes quick.
He caught Cyborg and an Armbar Cyborg.
Never saw that.
Common Cyborg was blast and him would lead.
Kicks to,
but it didn't matter.
It was like,
it was almost like he was just holding off the charge.
Who just holding off the time.
We'll get you.
I'm gonna get.
I'm gonna.
Get some finally Cyborg.
Like the pressure of constantly coming at him.
So I've walked into,
and by the way,
Kim down in nick had them arm barred and like,
no time.
Yeah,
he's an interesting dude.
Physically,
he's,
he's smaller than Anderson,
that's for sure.
You know,
he's fought at 55.
He's got to walk around.
What is it about six one?
Dick is at least six feet tall.
Six 1:10.
Anyway,
he ways he walks around.
And what do you think?
I don't know.
He's pretty healthy,
so he's not the type of dude that would gain a lot of ways.
He definitely never gets fat.
He's like very strict.
This diet.
I think he's mostly Vegan.
He's drinking Kombucha all the time telling me that.
Now I'm going to start doing the Nick Diaz Diet.
Well listen man,
if you talk to guys like rich roll or any of these like ultra endurance guys
like you know there's,
there's no better way to keep your body energized and constantly eating fresh
vegetables,
high,
high carbohydrate,
complex carbide.
Yeah.
I don't think for ultimate performance though,
for especially explosive performance,
I don't think you get the same results according to scientists.
You know,
the people that have actually done studies shows that there really are some
benefits to a complete.
It's a complete protein.
Yeah.
The thing about being a Vegan as you can get your protein,
but it,
I think the proteins at the end of the day or whenever they start to cohesion,
they sort of can't.
They pick up where the other ones left off.
So beans are one nuts have protein in and you had enough of that you'll get a
complete protein,
but meat is a very calorie dense energy dense,
a complete protein.
It's just better and most.
By the way,
most most cultures,
and you know this from the guy you had on,
I'm sure he talked about it with the Paleo Diet,
most hunter gatherer cultures,
the way we came up,
we were strictly carnivores.
I mean,
if you look at where we went hunting,
try planting anything there,
you would have had to live off animal protein
for the most part.
There's a lot of parts.
We were in Montana,
we went hunting for this,
uh,
Steven Rinella show.
It's called the mediator.
And the mediator is his second show.
He had this other show that was on,
um,
I think it was on the travel channel.
It's called the wild within.
It was really cool.
Show where you go,
like he went where Lewis and Clark went and the,
uh,
a shot a moose and made a boat out of the Moose and fucking shot loose with a
musket and made a boat out of the Moose.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I like the way they would have done it.
It was really interesting.
I make a bone out of a moose.
So Brian and I went hunting with them.
We went to a,
I talked about it with Ari Shaffir already,
but we went to Montana to what used to be the great inland Western,
see the Great Western inland sea,
which is fast willing to a part where he
lewis and Clark said they,
they as went through it,
they were like,
we think we saw some signs of native Americans.
I mean not even the native Americans lived there,
but it was a hunting role,
but you couldn't live there because you could grow.
Nothing crazy.
I use also weird how much ground we covered,
like wake up really early in the morning and then we'd,
you'd go,
he'd be like,
we'll go over that ridge.
I was like,
that rich has a mountain range.
Is it shit as far right.
But you could actually climb it because it was made a clay and it stuck to your
feet,
you know?
Well it was really difficult when you're on the edges because it was just so
slippery and your feet would waste so much because the,
the bottoms would be caked with this shit.
And I remember when I glassed the field,
I'd take my binoculars and look out for game glassing the field is a,
as a hunting terminology,
don't worry about it.
And I'd be so out of breath,
man,
because we were high elevation.
It was just like,
it was a lot of hiking that.
So you've got to be in fucking cheap,
you know,
I've watched this show and I've seen them,
what they do is stalking after the game.
But I never really considered how much actual walkers involved.
He just,
he doesn't get tired.
I know,
dude,
I was fucking super impressed because uh,
we were me and the camera guys fucking out of breath.
And Steve rebel is up their truck and you're walking forever.
Yeah.
When you're walking up some serious hills.
It's really interesting though.
We were talking about this,
that anything you do,
even like hiking,
if you're like,
he's doing this every week.
Every year he does it all year round.
That's how he hunts.
So he's like constantly hiking.
The central nervous system learns how to use your muscles more efficiently.
Yeah,
that's what we're talking about.
Like every,
anything you do with martial arts or wrestling,
why they tell you if you want a bodybuilder,
you gotta change it up because you confuse your central nervous system so your
body doesn't learn to use the same muscles over and over again.
Right?
So now your body's like confused and it goes,
well,
we got to use these muscles now and you keep tearing the muscles down and I
just,
that's what I want.
Can you just don't like the crossfit?
People believe in that as well.
That's like their,
their ideas.
You do some fitness fitness so your body gets to a comprehensive,
a strength,
you know,
sort of a all around kind of controversial too though.
The controversy behind the crossfit people is that some people like steven that
you should ever be doing power lifting exercises with great reputations like
that.
It's like there's no way they're designed for.
They're designed for big explosive movements,
moving heavy things with correct form and building up your core and your
explosive power.
Most of the people I know did crossfit and get hurt.
They get hurt.
There's a lot of injuries and in fact a lot of pro athletes that I've talked to
don't do it as much because first of all it's a little bit,
it's so much.
It's so much on your body that a lot of times they weren't having energy for
their practices or their games and it keeps you torn down.
Now there are some ridiculously fit athletes and I think it's a great program,
but I try to do it as much as possible,
but I do think that the athletes I've talked to the fighters and even the
football players are like,
well you gotta you gotta you gotta move at your own pace with that stuff.
Yeah,
you do.
You can't try to keep up with those dudes because those extreme crossfit dudes
they get.
They get like a deep,
deep,
deep into the game to the point where they can do just ridiculous sets with 225.
They're clean and jerking for 20 reps and then they're doing 20 chin ups grants.
Yeah.
They can do some sport.
It's not like,
you know,
I'm sure that it's a test of will man.
That is a test of will at crossfits humbling.
Every time you do it.
Like if you do Fran,
you know what Fran,
his friend never gets easy.
Like if I think about it,
my heart starts beating fast.
Where you got 95 pounds,
you go into a squat thrust,
you go squat,
thrust her.
So you go down in a squat position,
throw it up over your head.
You do that 21 times,
go at 21 pull ups,
15 thrusters,
15 pull ups,
nine thrusters,
nine pull ups.
And you know,
the idea is if you could do a sub,
if you it under three minutes here in ridiculous shape,
uh,
but even doing it,
try doing it in under seven or eight and you'll be on the ground.
It's just never.
It never gets easy.
They have so many of those things that never get easy to so much you could do
out there for exercise.
It's amazing.
You see most people at the gym,
they're like,
you're barely working out.
You know,
you might be doing curls.
Are doing some sets that you do though.
What's your,
how long is your workout?
If you're lifting,
it depends.
Depends on what I'm doing.
Depends on I started when I hurt my back,
I started doing more isolation stuff like rows and stuff like that just to
really strengthen up my back so that day is like an easy day.
The the fullback day that I do,
I do one full back day that's only like 30 minutes quick workout,
but just the whole idea is just to blow it out and make it really hard.
You know?
I just,
I want,
I just want to have,
be able to build up muscle and to have explosive power so your body's got to be
conditioned all the time to be doing explosive shit,
building up tissue exploding.
And if you don't do that all the time,
it doesn't want to do all the time.
You'll have no situation in life in which to explode.
And we all know that.
We use that every day.
Funny,
like I do all this stuff.
I'm like,
when am I ever going to do doing kettlebell?
Until I can't walk.
Like what am I going to not.
I'm not.
I'm not bringing huge bells,
but it doesn't matter.
I like being in shape in case the shit hits the fan.
I wasn't in shape,
but when we went on a hunting trip,
we've assured I would have been fucked.
Oh my God.
Because that was.
That was a series.
We would hike at least three miles in the morning.
So funny dude.
It was raining the first night we were freezing and the sleeping bags they gave
us didn't work and as I'm getting,
I'm shivering and putting like seven layers to down jackets.
Literally I'm shivering.
I just hear Jonas in his tank.
Go camping.
Fucking laughed so hard and somebody shoot.
You did.
I don't know why.
He just goes camping below.
We had a great fucking time.
How about me pulling fucking quilts out of your ass and legs?
I think we have on tape.
We still have these red marks all over my ass and legs.
I laid down on a cactus and Brian had a pull them out in the camp for the
campfire with all the guys.
All the guys were like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
I don't waste my fucking,
my best friend.
I got to pull out.
I'll take out your fucking thorns.
When I went to to drop down to kill the deer,
I sat down right in the cactus
pat covered and
you see your first year,
you want to kill that thing so badly.
I literally,
I had a bucket in my crosshairs that that third day when you got yours,
I couldn't.
I had talked about buck fever.
The scope was bleeding.
He jumping all over the place.
I was like,
this is my breathing.
The first time I couldn't get them into focus.
The first time I went to shoot it because in my I was too close to the scope and
then I realized what I was doing wrong.
I was like,
oh,
what am I doing over there?
Stupid like what?
What am I doing?
Like I was panicking.
I just got too close to the scope and it was like,
it's weird when you're looking at something through a scope,
it's very hard to describe,
but it's like almost like you're,
you're,
you see like black,
like half moons over everything.
Like you can't like close in on the actual image,
the outside of his all black.
Did you keep your eye from a scope and you stay and you start to be good at
that.
When you and I backed up just a hair and boom,
it was in perfect,
clear focus.
I was like,
oh,
that's it.
I was too close and then the fucker went behind a cliff.
The deer
by the way,
hunting deer hunting.
Mule deer in a place where they know they're being hunted a lot like hunting and
Mirage.
They'll just show up and then they just disappeared.
And you're like,
but how did it didn't go into the mountain?
Where is it?
Well,
they're so.
They're so well camouflaged.
They look exactly like the mountainside.
Yeah.
You don't see them until you see like a little white tuft where their assets.
Yeah,
I'm fine chasing for all morning.
I finally,
I got him on a stretcher,
got him and I'm like,
now we're this ridiculous.
There's no way they could have disappeared.
Then I see ducks and I'm like,
what are those?
Ducks have huge ears.
Oh,
those fuckers are swimming across the river.
I spent all morning chasing you assholes and now you're across the river and I
got no shot and uh,
yeah,
I didn't even know they can swim.
I didn't either.
They swabbed,
literally like swimming,
like,
you know,
like covering serious ground.
Where we went was so strange.
It was such a bizarre,
bizarre place.
Cold,
cold as fuck.
And it was,
it was just so unlike anything that you never ever do in your normal life is a
comedian in la.
It's so true.
We didn't have cell phones,
we didn't have text messages.
I haven't done that in a long time man.
And the crazy thing was.
Oh we will.
We'll talk about how you have energy all day.
Like even though you're not eating the best food.
I mean we had good food.
We had to like camp food,
like apples and we had like beef jerky and we had freeze dried meals that we
would have for dinner and protein bars and stuff like that.
It wasn't like we were malnourished.
No,
but we were talking about how you get there and it's so quiet.
You don't have access to your cell phone,
no Internet,
no nothing,
and I think,
I think you're not spending any time taking in stimulus.
You just take your spending time listening to your own breathing,
you know,
and responding and connecting with people.
And somehow I had such clarity of focus and energy on that whole time.
It,
it will.
I definitely don't think we're designed to,
to live the way we live.
You know,
we're trying to adapt and I think future generations will probably have some
physical capabilities that we don't have.
You know,
because one thing about autism is that fact that we are now you had these hyper
hyper like autistic people who are high functioning that can take in a
tremendous amount of stimulus,
see a room and count like you know,
everything in it that fast on one of this,
this guy won and requests was saying on Ted Dot Com.
He's a venture capitalist scientist and he said,
you know,
it may be that our brains,
because we're exposed in such a short period of time to 500 times a stimulus
that are we see more in one day than our ancestors saw on a you in a lifetime as
far as just the amount of stimulus,
the amount of sounds,
the thoughts that are crammed into our brains just through visual stimuli and
auditory stimuli said our brand is very well,
may already be evolving to match and coordinate with this ever changing
exponentially growing environment.
Well,
that's what I'm wondering about.
Like with Wifi Signal,
cellular signals and all the different.
There's like I don't understand signals,
you know,
I kind of know that they're there.
I know that there's radio.
I know that just television.
I know that there's stuff that's being sent out in somewhere.
Someone's receiving it,
but I don't understand it.
And so I don't understand like what is it doing to biology.
They know that it's having an effect on bees,
especially cell phone signals.
They think that it might be like a steady,
like jackhammer sort of thing that's affecting bees,
like just an interference,
like all member aliens is air,
so it's,
it's,
that's what the Wifi signal.
We talked about it yesterday.
I honestly think all this stuff is edging toward becoming one with the machines
for real and then ultimately to that effect,
creating this sort of universal connectedness.
I wonder if it's biological for very long.
I wonder if we're ever going to evolve.
Wait,
some ability to tune into these,
these signals without adding something to the body Audi
without adding like a chip.
Like how fucked would it be if the healing.
We are going to have chips way before that question arises.
I think things are moving so quickly.
We have synthetic,
uh,
we're working on synthetic,
biological,
synthetically biological computer chips,
faces.
We're going to have like a google face.
You're going to get a new face.
I bet.
I bet you could probably do that some day.
Well,
that's what Ray Kurzweil says.
Yeah.
I mean we're,
we're going to be,
we're going to mesh with machines.
Why in the world if you had an eye that could see a mile away and in the dark,
why wouldn't you get an an artificial lie?
Why wouldn't you?
That's exactly what I'm old school.
I don't need my leg.
I'm going to sit here on my porch until everything stops.
Yeah.
Why would you?
But maybe you know,
maybe the next life is better.
Maybe the better.
I don't even know if there is.
Maybe the afterlife is the notion that you live on is a computer as a computer
program.
I mean,
right.
That's.
Look,
it's not opposite.
if I can download,
I can download your brain.
Everything that goes onto your brain.
I can download all the content.
Right?
Which,
which computer science you're talking about a matter of when?
Not if like numb my brain.
Like maybe you're not here,
you're a brand new car.
He's a huge mainframe.
Too much going,
but then I take that brand and I put everything,
all your memories and everything to think about into a computer.
I can put it into a robot maybe.
Well,
what does that say about your mortality?
no,
I don't know the answer.
It's we only accepted if it's,
if it's legit,
if it's natural,
that's when we accept things when they're natural,
you know,
if you hate it.
We,
we've been,
for example,
genetically modifying
crops like corn and things that you would never recognize what corn was 200,
300 years ago.
It's a different,
you know,
it's,
it's everything you eat,
everything including the animals you eat has been genetically fucked with to
become more productive in their output and isn't ultimately.
I mean we're calling it natural.
What's natural and not natural but isn't everything that human beings do natural
because we're part of nature.
Absolutely.
Just as natural as the process of making honey.
But the other question,
the other issue is that yes,
the idea of the very idea of natural and biology is going to change when we
realize that this,
this human being that I'm looking at is a machine like anything else.
In fact,
a rather rudimentary machine maybe 300 years from now or 200 years from now or
50 years from now.
It may very well be that we,
once we figured out exactly how the machine works with the genome and all these
other ideas,
well I guess I could make now even a more complex machine,
so in the end of the day,
if that machine is just as biological but more complex than this rusty old
machine that breaks down after 90 years or whatever.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know what biology means anymore.
What happens to the bacteria that exists in the biological organism because
that's like our,
our tenants.
Well,
first of all,
we're already well,
but already what we're doing,
what science is doing is trying to learn how to harvest and,
and,
uh,
the good bacteria versus the bad bacteria and manage the body like an ecosystem,
a mini ecosystem and science.
More and more scientists are,
are talking that the microbes that make up our body are,
are,
are exactly why we are the way we are.
They control everything from the,
the natural moisture in our skin to the way we smell to personality.
Let's say the,
yeah,
it might have an effect on intelligence.
Autism may be connected,
certain types of autism spectrum disorders might be connected to having an
imbalanced flora.
It's.
It's fascinating,
man.
It's the human body's a host for life.
There's billions and billions of organisms living inside your body.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's hard for us to really imagine that we're not an individual.
You know?
It's hard for us to imagine that we're a walking ecosystem.
Yeah.
That's also the idea that,
you know,
it's maybe hard to imagine that we are,
we are being nudged in a certain direction.
It's not this not chaos.
There's,
there's a direction we're being moved in and its complexity always from,
from the beginning of humans.
True to the moment they figured out how to roll things on logs.
They have made it more and more and more and more complex.
Yeah.
That's just what the only thing that's not as complex as our stone work know,
like ancient Egyptian stonework.
We had a guy in yesterday,
Philip Copans,
who's this,
wrote this great book on lost civilization,
enigma.
It's all on,
you know,
like the ancient constructions of the past and that's the only thing like today
that we still go,
God damn,
these motherfuckers had some crazy technology and some crazy insight that the
Egyptians,
the Egyptians,
I mean even the,
the Romans and a lot of other people who have made some incredible pieces of
architecture.
It doesn't mean we couldn't do it today.
Well,
we are doing it today,
but I think on a,
on a subatomic level or a national level,
right?
Oh,
sure,
sure.
Now,
now most of the innovation is going toward creating robotics and tissue
regeneration.
Growing new limbs,
we were talking about it that we think that change that light.
Hold on the idea.
Change a light.
What's in your eyes?
This thing back here.
Are Your eyes sensitive?
My friend
that they did call you.
I,
you know what a game I,
his folks.
So it's when you're in the canoe and you're rowing,
you look up in the hills and if you see the aim,
you're,
you got the game.
I,
we saw a lot of,
they called him.
He came by the cashmere killer because I was wearing three layers of cashmere
hunting deer and freezing my fucking tail off.
Still Fun.
It was really fun.
I'm so glad you went with me,
man.
It would have made it.
It made it a hundred times better.
We did.
Was laugh the whole time.
It was just great time.
There was a time,
I mean it's such a disrespectful moment because we're actually butchering the
deer,
but as we were butchering this deer,
we're cutting into sections and I don't know what possessed him,
but he got it to this thing of jerking off into the ravine.
My character was the ravine cut,
so he starts doing this character where he's angry about stuff with its tongue
sticking out side of his mouth that he's just jerked off into the ravine and it
was so preposterous for what was happening mean.
Here we are like skinning this animal and hocking chopping it couldn't take the
sections off of him.
It was really weird skinning an animal and gutting it and skinning it,
and so I know the problem is if you put me in a sacred place,
I start to freak out and do something,
but you should've seen me at church.
I went to church like four times in my life.
I couldn't do it.
Dude,
I'd start doing crazy shit.
Well,
that's what I told him.
I was like listening to having this guy with this.
It's gonna make the whole thing 100 times funnier.
Trust me.
We're going to have a great time.
Especially you and I together.
You and I had together have a.
We have,
uh,
you're one of my longest running friends in La and we have a.
yeah,
we know each other so well.
We've been through so much shit.
Brian,
I,
I sent my,
uh,
I've sent Brian to fuck my ex girlfriend was because I had a girlfriend at the
time and I didn't want to cheat.
She's like,
God,
I'm so horny.
And like,
like I'll hook you up.
I'll go,
hey,
go even looks like me.
Played my brother on news radio.
Remember that?
That was great.
She was fantastic when I was at fucking dirty,
dirty girls
dated this girl
for a while.
I think like,
Hey,
I want my friend to fuck my head.
Shit.
Let's.
First of all I knew me and that girl will never get them back together again.
No disrespect to her nice personnel.
That kid,
but I knew it was never happened again and he's my boy.
He doesn't care.
Give a fuck.
She needed some Dick to Brian,
give you a hunting trip.
She's my friend.
She needed some Dick.
You know,
what am I supposed to do?
Say you know,
you're,
you know I can't help you.
I can help her.
I had the fucking solution called me up.
I'm setting.
Yeah.
What are you doing tomorrow?
I don't know that I said you're going to go fuck my ex.
I think
he fucked her behind a car and shot a load into her and she calls me the next
day.
Your fucking friend came inside me.
I was,
what am I supposed to do?
Laughing so hard.
I was crying.
I was holding back because I know you so well.
You're so fucking crazy and that could believe that we did it in the first
place.
I said,
you have to go.
Fuck her.
I'm not even just laughing while you.
She's telling me fucking friend Kate with.
I get very few ex-girlfriends,
whoever called me up complaining
not to.
I was younger having sex.
Aren't I supposed to do that?
I don't know.
That's funny thing.
I.
Yeah.
You think about how fucking what a numbskull I was when I was younger,
just I didn't understand girls were different.
I didn't really understand
why they were just like me and then I dated a girl who'd be like looking back on
it.
They were all great and I'd be like,
why am I.
Why?
Why is she not behaving like my friends?
She's a fucking girl.
You idiot.
It takes a while to understand that I was just a fucking idiot.
Were those poor girls were like,
what is with this,
this,
this caveman?
You know,
I'm not gonna fuck you in the elevator.
This is whenever it was.
I bought.
Well you should be more into.
I broke up with a girl because she fell asleep during raging bull.
That's not fair to a girl.
It's a great movie,
but it's a fucking movie about a boxer.
The guys like girls aren't supposed to.
You know.
It's not fair for me to be mad.
I was like,
this is one of the great.
This is my favorite movie of all time and you fell asleep in it.
I'm afraid I have nothing in common with you.
I didn't say that,
but I made that choice in my head.
I was like,
well,
she hot.
Yes,
but I was like,
I don't know
what is.
One of the things that I pride myself in is I've never tried to make someone
that I've dated any different than who they are.
You are always good to learn.
I was a fucking idiot.
Well,
I just know.
Is it more for me,
it was just like,
how can we bring someone,
tell them they have
to read it.
I was like,
how can you not be interested in this?
This is amazing.
Well,
they were fucking thing.
They got their own thing.
They were smarter than I was.
I looked back on it,
they knew if I had listened to them I would have,
I would've been better off.
There's a lot of things that people I like really love and I could not care less
if it existed,
whether it's sports or certain types of music and I could love these person,
these people to death and whatever their opinion is.
I just like Eddie Bravo was always trying to turn me onto some new electronic
band and like four out of five of them are pretty decent,
but every now and then there's,
you know,
he's,
he's into some shit that I'm not into a fiery series.
Those are pretty high odds.
I bet it's less than that.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
It's about three,
three out of five.
So nice being nice because I love Eddie.
Three of it,
but it's not luck.
It's just taste in music.
Like he really loves smashing pumpkins.
He really loves Leonard Skinner Guy.
I'm a led Zeppelin guy.
I love like hearing the fucking guitar scratching on the pit.
You know what I mean?
I want,
I want to hear like the black keys,
like that's my cousin.
Also musicians,
a lot of times we're listening to something different than we are here more than
we do or they're just more in tune with something innovative or Eddie has a very
specific style that he fucking loves and you know,
and he's very creative man.
I mean his own music.
He's like,
if you're,
if you're into that style of music,
like Eddie does some really topnotch shit and now he does it with this dude
compel a.
They have this band called smoke serpent and like compel who's a really good
rapper like wraps over it and it plays like,
you know,
Eddie puts his music on the background and his thing has always been that like
he always loved hip hop but he didn't like the kind of music that was in the
background of hip hop.
He didn't like that whole sampling fan and thought it would be,
you know,
he liked,
he's got like that sort of electronic,
a smashing Pumpkin,
sort of a vibe of music.
He's really into that.
Everybody's different.
Why that is everybody's fucking different.
Wiring right,
yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
look,
there's some people who hate violence and hate violence sports.
They don't.
I mean they just don't like it,
but I can have great conversations with them about other stuff.
You know,
there's.
Listen man,
I just thought it was so funny the minute I saw that dear and I had one shot to
get this to you because you,
you go all day looking for deer and you don't see what it was so cold.
I,
the minute I saw that book,
My hat came off everything.
I didn't feel anything.
I was just literally like,
I'm going to kill that fucking book.
I,
I'm not a hunter and I don't really necessarily want to kill.
So we were on a mission.
You know what?
We were doing something that was very unusual for two guys that are in their
forties with kids living in La,
in the entertainment business,
sort of sort of still in entertainment business.
I do comedy shows,
I guess the there on my own,
but I mean,
I guess,
but you know,
those guys were a great audience,
weren't they?
Are Guides.
Stanford,
Ella and Ryan,
what's his last name?
Ryan.
Ryan Callahan,
who's a great guy.
Was My,
uh,
my,
my guide ride,
mow the director.
God I can't wait to do.
They were all great guys and these guys are solid as fuck man.
They were a great audience.
Loved that.
He just laughed at us fucking around all the time.
Well,
I don't think they'd probably ever done a show like that.
You know,
Brian went like,
from the moment we got there where I was full tilt from the moment we got there,
he was,
this is all mining.
See this,
this is a longterm strip mining.
And I go,
no,
I go,
this is the Missouri River.
You fucked this cut through this.
It used to be the great western indigency no,
no,
no.
This is mine.
I was talking to Steve Right now.
It's been there and I grew up there like,
yeah,
this is my,
this is not.
This is all natural.
I go,
you're wrong about that.
But anyway,
right away he gets into his ridiculous character and then it gets gay or queer
cracking.
I'm cracking jokes.
So as long as cracking job,
that's all I'm living for at that point.
So I'm like,
if I got an audience I can just see Joe's eyes.
They're slits and he's like,
oh my God,
that's fucking it.
It was like,
it was seriously no bullshit.
Like going on a five day comedy show where inbetween you took breaks to go.
We have a lot on camera.
We got it.
We got to steal it and put it on the fucking.
Well there's certain things like they said that they were going to give it to us
because they could never put it on their show,
but he a
lot of control on this show.
I think it's on the sportsmans channel,
one of those channels towards hunting shows,
which by the way,
I watch now and watch all these hunting shows.
Now I'm fucking recording them and watching hunting channels that you do it.
It's so fast and you know what it's like,
I didn't get it.
You're in the middle of nowhere.
You never going to see this topography and then you see a deer,
you see like something that you could actually get.
And I,
I love deer meat by the way,
but,
but you know,
you see it and you're like everything.
It's like winning the lottery.
It's like almost sudden you're like,
Whoa,
this whole rush,
you know,
of discovering something new.
Well,
you're in their world.
That's the weirdest thing about what it is,
is when you do this sort of what they call immersion hunting.
We,
we basically went into the wild,
like the real legitimate wild.
It's not a road that's untraveled.
People travel it every year,
but it's not that many.
And the people that are traveling are all doing what you're doing.
They're all sneaking up on deers and shooting them.
And while we were there,
we were there for five days.
We saw three other canoes.
So that was it to two other campsites.
So what it is,
is this really inhospitable terrain that occasionally,
you know,
every couple of days or so a new person will venture into.
And it's that crazy.
It's another world.
This world doesn't have any cell phone signal.
You don't see a building anywhere.
You get on top of the mountain and you climb up for hours,
you get to the top and you look out and it's Kinda scary because you don't see
shit for anywhere to the left or to the right.
It's more of these hills and valleys,
hills and valleys and no help.
No stores,
no nothing.
So you got what you brought with you and what you can kill here and cook.
That's right.
That's exactly right.
And so when you creep up on a deer and wind up shooting that deer and killing
it,
like you like entered into a,
like a different reality,
you like plugged into this different reality of hunting also.
Like I thought the most profound part of it was butchering my own deer.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you why it was we,
we have a real disconnect to the food we'd right.
So you go to Mcdonald's and you're eating a steer that was maybe killed,
I don't know how many months ago,
you know,
and,
and then the skin by some stranger and then quartered and put together and grind
in process with other beef cows.
And it's a mixture of shit,
maybe some of the cows came from China,
so I'm guessing it's the same thing with chicken and stuff and you see there's a
real disconnect with the kind of the animal protein that we don't know how it's
lived.
We don't know how it's suffered.
We don't know anything about it.
And that's always bothered me.
And one of the things I thought was there were two things I found profound
about,
about not only killing a deer with that rifle,
the,
the force and the feeling of it,
you know,
but also,
um,
then butchering the meat,
the,
the intimate process of,
of gutting a deer and harvesting the liver and the heart.
And then,
and then cutting a skinning it and cutting into that,
that meat that you're going to eat,
the heat,
the heat from the inside of its body because you got to get in there,
you know.
Um,
I had blood,
we both had blood.
I had passed my wrists.
And the intimate process of doing that,
the smell and the feel and the temperature,
you really get a sense of the,
the vast discrepancy between life and death and our own biology and how fragile,
you know,
we are like,
you see what a scalpel,
what a small knife can do to muscle and skin and sinew.
It's frightening.
It's frightening how easy it is to gut a deer,
which is much stronger animal than I am.
You know,
it's,
it's just frightening to think about.
So it creates in your,
in your own sort of visceral sense of true vulnerability and more importantly,
our own biology and I,
I then had a very strong understanding that idea of how easy it was for hunter
gatherer or even our very recent ancestors to kill another human being.
Because when you kill an animal and you butcher it and you get that close to its
body and its heart and its life force and then you see it go away.
Killing a human being would be exactly the same thing and a lot of ways because
it's just another animal.
Now obviously we have different motifs on what a human being is.
They have a conscience and all that and blah,
blah,
but I'm just saying that I can understand how a hunter would make a very good
and ready warrior.
There's A.
There's a very,
very thin divide and most of us as men in today's world don't ever experience
either one.
We don't have experienced death that that intimately.
We don't experience even fighting that intimately.
Everything has to be simulation.
It has to be either a fucking video game or a legitimate.
Yeah,
but not even that.
You're saying a Jujitsu match.
That's the rarest of the rare.
Usually it's an argument in traffic.
Oh,
I'm.
That's virtually no testing yourself.
Like right.
No connection to life and death like that.
Yeah,
I mean that's one of the grateful.
It made me warm,
respectful of deer of the being
up being with a hunter like Ryan or Steve.
What you realize actually is at hunters to be an effective hunter,
the irony is you have to have a deep,
deep respect,
love and understanding of the animal.
It's behavior and of the environment in which you are now a guest in.
No,
listen,
it's not easy.
It's not easy.
I mean,
people think you're just going out there and shooting defenseless animals.
No,
you're.
What you're doing is you're going out and getting your own meat and it's a
difficult fucking process.
It's very difficult and you guys were really good at it.
Those guys love every aspect of it.
The ryans and the Steve,
Steve Rainelle and Ryan Callahan.
Those guys that took us out there.
They love every aspect of their conservationists.
Yeah,
true conservationist.
They follow the rules to a t.
They know every rule for every area of their hunting.
The pay attention to all of it.
Like where we were at,
we couldn't use two way communication so no one could say like,
hey,
we saw some deer,
this one,
and you can't say that over the radio.
It's illegal.
Do you know what happened to me when I was hunting?
It changed my political point of view a little bit.
Really?
Yeah.
You know why?
Why?
Well,
this is weird because I was talking about being a libertarian and everything
else,
but then I realized the value and the importance of having strong regulation and
rules for because if you talk to hunters and people are really know without
really strong anti poaching laws,
for example,
are really strong regulation by the fish and game service,
you would have everybody that I've talked to a grace,
you'd have major abuses by assholes,
just machine gunning the whole fucking side of that Ridge when they saw rams and
you'd have no game left and in fact American history and history in the Middle
East certainly that I know of,
but bears that out,
that that,
that people always over hunted,
they always overfished and they continued to do that.
People are concerned that they wouldn't.
When,
when our ancestors figured out that you could run woolly mammoths off a cliff,
guess what?
William man has disappeared.
You know,
and they start.
I mean that.
That's the,
this is what happens.
So human beings actually can be very short sighted and can like kind of not do
what's in their best interest.
Sometimes you need,
you need,
you need some regulation.
Well,
you didn't.
You didn't think that the fishing game,
that was a good idea,
but I didn't know.
I didn't know about it.
I just always have a visceral reaction to any government organization and I go,
well,
are they making it worse or better?
No,
there are some very good and important.
They're the probably government regulation.
It's all done by hunters.
It's all done by people who will hopefully.
I think there was some dispute about who was going to be in charge of it.
Now it's like people who are more animal rights oriented.
No,
I don't trust her neighbor and Ela and guys like Ryan have are huge believers in
the.
A huge lovers of animals.
Yeah,
and the other thing is,
man,
the people can't deny that it needs to be done because there's only two options.
Either you hunt the animals or you reintroduce predators,
and when you reintroduce predators,
you've got a whole new set of problems.
First of all,
you've cut down on some eat free meat.
So unless you're saying that people should stop eating meat.
Totally.
You've cut down on the amount of meat you've,
you've,
you've cut down on the most humane way of ever harvesting an animal,
letting the animal live his entire life wild and normal and undisturbed until
you take it,
so literally as a free animal and you go and earn it and get that animal.
It's an animal trapped in a pen that you forced into a corralled area.
Then it gets a piston through the brain.
It's like it's the main plot,
so I don't understand why you would want people to stop doing it.
Is it the idea that people are upset at the idea of someone actually taking the
life themselves?
I mean,
that must be.
That's the only argument I can see.
You know,
maybe it's stayed.
They recognize that that connection between taking that animal and you,
that animals is very close to the connection of taking a human life.
My issue with hunting is like I would.
I would not hunt a bear or a lion or something that I'm not going to eat.
I don't believe in that.
I don't like hunting.
Mountain lions stays good.
Steven Ellis said that mountain lion steak is delicious.
Yeah,
I read it.
He talks about it in the book.
He's got tasting notes on mountain lions.
Pretty funny on the media,
but I,
I,
um,
it's actually,
it's,
it's hit or miss with mountain lions sometimes it's so string you can't even
literally can't even chew into it.
Then other times you gotta if you roast it for a long time in a stew,
like a slow cooker,
it's kind of a pale meat in it.
It's got,
it's got an okay taste.
But in fact,
in fact,
eating predators that eat that live on animal protein is,
is not such a good idea except fish except for fish.
Fish are all delicious.
Lead fish.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
That's why you catch them with lures.
But um,
but fucks with a,
it's like throwing a robot in front of you that you think you could fuck it.
Dive on an Prong,
sticking your ass hole and you get dragged into another dimension.
It's like so rude about what you say.
It's like rude things to eat.
Things with their face.
Yeah.
You catch them by the face?
Well,
the dive sites,
so afraid of the ocean.
It's.
It's shouldn't be.
Have you seen the ocean at night?
Dark when it's dark.
Pitch Five.
I've been on it in a boat before.
It was terrifying.
Me Too.
My parents lived on a sailboat for a couple of years.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
My parents got a wild hair across the ass and they decided to retire and kicked
back for Awhile and my dad just stopped working for a few years.
He went back to work afterwards,
but he stopped working for a few years and just sailed around the world.
They lived in the Bahamas for awhile.
They looking for and they get stuck in a hurricane.
Once you have it,
then I always worry about pirates and things.
Yes,
I need.
I mean if I can have a turret gun and if I can,
50 caliber sniper rifle and a seal team following me until we address the
imbalance of the world.
Brian calendar is always going to be pirates.
It's,
you know,
we always,
we're always concerned with fattening up our own pockets,
but unless we feed those poor people of Somalia,
they're going to keep doing what they want to do.
I agree.
How do you fix that?
Like the Somalia thing,
so it's literally an area the size of Texas are known.
The Western Europe.
I mean that,
that area that they talk about is so vast and yes,
you're going to have very poor people who come in and go,
let's,
let's hijack that very big boat and take whatever.
You don't even,
you know,
how it started.
Do you know the Somalian thing started,
they call themselves the volunteer coastguard of Somalia because what happened
was the Somalian people were essentially fishermen and European started dumping
toxic waste off their and fishing.
They're shorts,
overfishing,
their shores with nets and shit and using,
uh,
did you hear that?
Or was it just made you hear that pop?
I didn't hear you and polluting it with all sorts of toxic waste and just fucked
up their whole ecosystem.
So all of a sudden these people can't fish anymore.
So they started holding these people captive,
they would catch one of these fishing boat or when these boats dumping shit off
their coast,
they would kidnap them and they would demand a ransom because you guys are
fucked up our fishing,
we want some money,
and then they realize,
you know what,
fuck fishing,
let's just start jacking.
Do It's all these people are in boats.
They all want.
Everybody's going to want them back.
And so they just started taking over boats.
So it was total chaos.
Yeah.
I always think about that navy seal guy that actually on a boat as it was
bobbing up and down shot that dude with a headshot.
It's incredible.
It's his boat was bobbing up and down.
What you call good marksmanship.
If I used a mag 300,
apparently the guy dropped that deer with it was what?
The seal team.
Some of the seal teams and I produce.
That was a sick gun.
The gun was pretty awesome.
It was really accurate.
You,
you shot really well till you dropped your deer at what?
Two hundred yards and then they said it was a great shot.
It was a,
it's hard to stay calm,
but like I said,
I'm so used to doing things when I'm nervous.
I think it helped me to like knowing how to stay calm once I went,
once I remembered to just control my breathing and just focus on my trigger
finger.
It was everything stopped.
It's so easy to say,
but it's so hard to get a calm,
relaxing because you're,
you're also trying to calm yourself down with a breath to begin with usually in
seconds because it's fucking thing is not going to stay still.
It's not because things moving so as it's trying to be on your belly and you
know he had quills in your fucking leg.
Steven Nyla blue,
a little horn that like,
it sounds like a fun,
like,
like a little thing and the deer won't like this and then boom,
he just shot him.
Yeah,
it's fucked up man.
The whole process of it was fascinating.
Then eating it that night.
Well,
you had gotten a deer and I was so worried I wasn't going to get a deer
and then I was like,
we're going for a buck,
and then I found out we could actually shoot bucks her dose and and he turns out
and he goes,
do you want to shoot a doe?
I go,
fuck,
yeah,
I want to shoot.
I'll shoot out a.
that's a big issue for a lot of people are gonna shoot a girl.
Well,
you know what else is interesting about where we were hunting as they were
talking about the huge winter kills.
Most of those mule dealer don't make it through the winter
cold more than predators.
Although we did find some mountain line shits.
We found some big fat,
thick shit feeling filled with hair.
Really?
Yeah.
He was like,
man,
he goes out to either one hell of a coyote or a mountain lion.
It goes most likely amount line.
It's pretty big piece of shit.
Wow.
Big Fat Mountain Lion Asshole was as big as the shift that you took of me.
Uh,
no.
Was different than your shit.
It was more like Midi.
Yeah,
they don't have any fucking vegetables or oatmeal in there.
that's true.
I took a photo of Brian Shit and we played a flag.
He made a tin foil flag,
posted planet it next to my shit,
but I did this.
I did a launch and presented it to him and he took a picture.
Hey Buddy.
Well I was gonna say on twitter that Brian took the shit off the Missouri River
and we put a flag next to it.
If you can go find it,
I'll give you a thousand dollars.
And I was going to have a twitter contest to find brands shit.
But you have to use these,
these waste bags.
You can't just leave your shit laying around on the Missouri River.
It's foul.
You have to dig it up and put it in these waste bags or shit in the bag itself.
And the bag has like some powdered chemical in it that kills the smell and use
zip it up and seal it.
So we had to essentially carry five days worth of shits with us.
The whole thing was,
is living like that was really fascinating.
And Man,
when we got back to that hotel room on the fifth day,
we,
uh,
we landed our boats.
We traveled like 40 something miles by canoe and you know,
everyday it was like six miles hiking.
And when we got back stunk,
stunk,
terrible.
But when I got in that shower,
oh my God,
I was so appreciative.
We had a great meal with the wine.
It was great.
What was the name of that place we went to?
I think,
what was it called?
It's really good.
It was Walter.
Walter's.
No walkers,
walkers.
Really Nice people too.
Great play built,
built like billings.
Montana is like,
surprisingly like diverse.
We saw a black guy there,
a couple of black guys saw several gay general,
a lot of gay jumping at the,
uh,
who are sitting at our table in fact at one point and sound more working at a as
waiters.
And I felt at home I was like this,
it looks like la or New York.
It was a gay guy.
Was swabbing gossip with me.
It was awesome.
It was telling him,
Oh yes,
he was telling me about this one and that one,
and then there was the guy that we met that had a stroke because he did too much
math.
I remember him,
handsome guy,
but he just had a stroke.
Fucking meth is bad.
Folks never did math and went,
you know,
when everything worked out,
I feel that this dude got a stroke from Matthew was 23 years old.
He had a fucking meth stroke.
Like whoa.
So he's a,
he's a recovering from that.
But,
but like the kitchen is like,
you know,
they were all like hipsters working there.
The chef at this big knife tattoo on his forearm,
you know,
it's like,
it's really interesting.
Like you're here,
you are in this what used to be thought of as a cow town,
like a classic cowtown in billings,
Montana.
But in fact it's like really kind of a cool town.
A lot of cool and interesting Peter,
a lot of gems,
hidden gems like that in this country.
A Columbia,
Missouri is just an unbelievable little town.
Ann Arbor,
Michigan,
Ann Arbor in our base thing,
it's called a comedy showcase.
I am doing helium this weekend,
Friday,
Saturday,
helium,
and is one of the all time great clubs really is.
Com.
Get your tickets.
Helium,
comedy.com.
Just go to Brian's twitter.
You got plenty of twitter.
I'm putting it up,
but you don't have it up yet and you're there this weekend.
Should have you son of a bitch tweeting right now.
I'll put it out.
We'll put it up after the show.
I'll do it for you.
Have you done Gotham in New York?
I'll be out on Gotham weekend.
Yeah,
I used to do that.
All the is my boy.
I mean Chris,
uh,
Chris,
Ms Dot Lee.
Who owns it?
Yeah.
Gotham is a great club.
It's another one of the best clubs.
Took one of the best clubs.
I think my favorite place to play in New York.
I used to do caroline's when I came into town,
but caroline's has that stage.
It's so small.
I'm actually hosting on Thursday the 15th I'm hosting got live at Gotham,
which they're shooting again.
Oh yeah,
that'll be fine.
Then I then I have my own.
I did that once and doing two shows Friday on the 16th of shows,
Saturday on the 17th of November.
So come by Gotham comedy club.
Definitely.
It was fun.
I did.
Yeah,
you did it.
In fact,
I was with you when you.
I wasn't even doing standup and you got up and did a sat there a long time ago.
Yeah,
he killed it.
It was me and patty.
We watched you and a profit patty,
powerful batteries and you should get her on that podcast.
She's fucking.
Would love to talk about the afterlife on my podcast.
She was so fucking good.
Patty's Patty's Brian's a ex girlfriend who's also a brilliant director.
Just a fascinating trip.
She is so rare because she's very.
She's so very dude.
Like,
like when you're having conversations with her,
like yeah,
she's very dude.
Like,
like what she was describing to me like,
like situations,
like actress breakdowns and craziness and you know,
her,
the kind of stuff that she has to manage being a director.
Like sometimes it's like babysitting,
you know,
like we always hear like Kevin pollock was on Opie and Anthony yesterday and was
talking about some instances he had on a set with Michael Clarke Duncan being a
diva and he told the whole story about it and even after the guy was dead,
you know,
but it's like they all have these fucking stories.
Like every director,
every person who works a set,
they all have these nutty stories of some.
David just told me that he interviewed me on his podcast.
Lorenzo Lamas,
by the way,
I just did dove on my podcast,
a unmanned thoughts,
which I'm posting today.
You guys might of like how he talks.
He went to a psychiatrist of and you know what the psychiatrist said after 20
minutes.
He goes,
ah,
I see what's going on here.
He goes,
what?
you actually don't think you have a right to be born.
I mean,
you don't,
you don't think you have a right to exist.
Is that how you feel?
That was like,
yeah,
that's exactly how I feel.
Yeah.
Really?
We talked about it in a fucking podcast.
Davidoff doesn't feel like he should have the right to,
you know,
how he grew up at the very.
It's,
it's his fucking life.
I mean,
Renee Zellweger starring and directing the movie of his life.
She's playing,
just playing the girl that likes him.
Love Him.
She's playing dumb.
Imagine if johnny,
Johnny,
Knoxville is playing Doug Davidoff wow.
And a story about his life.
That's a fascinating.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm posting the fucking,
uh,
the podcast today.
Dove a dove,
right?
Like all the dialogue and everything.
So it's all.
Or as he,
he,
it was initially his thing and he can't.
And I put them together with Anthony Tan back is my buddy wrote warrior and then
he was saying,
hey,
anthony is such a bad ass writer mean he fucking every drafted come up with.
You'd be like,
how the fuck do you write?
This warrior was a strange movie because it didn't get the attention that I
thought it deserved.
I saw them moving.
I was like,
wow,
that's going to be a,
that's going to be a big hit movie.
The only problem with that movie was the two day fighting thing.
They,
they fought two days in a row.
I was like,
man,
I felt like he could have got around that,
you know,
like had everything up to that.
I mean it was really,
there was some cliched topics and cliched angles,
but it was done so fucking.
Well.
Everybody from Nick naulty down to the two brothers.
I mean,
it was really done well.
It was a great fucking movie.
I enjoyed the shit out of it,
man.
And my wife enjoyed it.
She doesn't really like even like tested higher with women than it did with men.
It's good.
Fucking movie was good fucking movie,
but for whatever reason it just disappeared.
Like I didn't get it.
I was,
I was confused.
There's a lot of times that happens man,
where a movie like this will just slip through.
And a movie like that too.
It was so epic and so much was put into it and I made $6,000,000 or something
until the weekend.
It's just such a heartbreak,
you know?
It's too bad I don't get it.
I would have,
I would've thought that movie would have taken off.
Maybe it's just people were just like,
Whoa,
we got a problem.
Brian.
The thing just popped.
Really launched as the headphone Jack.
I think it is actually.
That's what it really.
Brian,
how do you know?
Oh you fuck you're moving things.
That's why it's popping.
Ha solved the problem.
Son of a bitch.
This is a new thing actually that we got.
I ordered one of those studio.
Anyway.
Where were we?
I'm talking about
the movie only made $6,000,000 and it's heartbreak.
It's either writing anything in life and,
and you know,
doing a movie or I didn't and it takes a long time building a business.
It's all an act of faith man.
And guess what?
Sometimes it just doesn't fucking work.
You just also problem is you're dealing with a giant group of people and trying
to everybody's vision,
trying to funnel them into one sort of cohesive laser beam.
Listen man.
It's like I told you I had to sit down with Mr Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Just just me,
him,
John,
John Leguizamo.
You had a good time,
Huh?
Well now what was the reason I bring it up as he was talking about being
governor for eight years and how fucking getting anything done.
It was basically impossible,
so he'd have a really common sense measure,
let's say measuring the groundwater for farmers because we can use more of that
water to go,
you know,
we can use the.
We don't need all this water,
let's measure the ground you and we'll siphon the rest off and La and the
farmers look at him and go,
oh,
that's not going to happen.
It's like,
what do you mean?
It's common sense will be right back.
Three hours later at seven Republican senators up in his office got Mr. Ms Dot
Gov.
You can't tell you we're not going to the ground water.
It's not
going to happen,
but here's what we'll do you you call for a measuring of the groundwater and
we'll act like a basically when and then the farmers won't let us on the land.
Everybody went down and you get it.
You get it now.
How's that?
Ha Ha.
He's literally saying it's.
You're dealing with such powerful special interests.
He said the only thing I could do as a governor was Vito Shit,
you know,
and he.
So by the way,
talking to him,
he's so socially liberal.
He's,
I mean I'm right down the,
this guy he's talking about,
he's just fiscally conservative.
He's talking about the insanity of the pull yourself up by the seat of your
pants,
but he's also very socially liberal.
He believes in like,
you know,
marriage and.
Yeah.
And also like he believes that we should do something about global warming.
He's got regulations.
He's a,
he's a very.
I'm right there.
I'm right with them on practically.
And as he was speaking he was just so fair minded and,
and but common sense measures,
common sense farming policy in this country where you don't subsidize huge
factory farms.
Try doing that sometime.
Try getting elected.
They just,
this shit is the,
these people spend all day.
Do they spend all day down in Capital Hill?
When's the last time you were petitioning?
Capitalist system is stupid.
It's really stupid.
But you got,
you got big labor unions that can make or break your election.
You have.
Obama's had been talking about special interest groups who's been talking about
getting where the lobbyists,
you know,
it's,
it's hard though because constitutionally you're allowed to petition your
government.
So how do you get around that?
I don't know.
I mean there is a way constitutionally the bill of rights used to also have a
lot of shit and it's not there anymore because of Patriot Act Nda.
You could easily fix that too.
You could just,
it seems like the idea of a lobbyist,
it should be completely illegal.
It should be completely illegal that you can have something wrong with the fact
that all those counties around capital hill or the wealthiest counties and they
don't produce a goddamn thing just as lawyers and lobbyists,
they don't produce anything.
What they do is they go,
they and holding up the various companies and they go and say,
Hey,
Mr,
Mr Sen,
uh,
you need to vote for this because it'll bring a lot of jobs also to your
constituency.
We need a new airplane and Boeing happens to have a plant.
There you will,
you'll hire 1100 people.
Just vote for it.
Yeah.
They don't look weak on defense system,
gangsters,
they find a system and they exploit the weaknesses in the system and that's
where we're at.
So we have to deal with all these weaknesses and he can't.
He can't just say,
well,
you know,
this is fine.
We just need to add some more laws and the,
no,
no.
You gotta do it shouldn't be the whole thing.
Should be.
It shouldn't be parsed down to some really simple language and you need to get
all outside influence out of it.
It has to completely be the will of the people and if people choose to act like
in groups as far as like,
you know,
religious groups on a boycott things or you know,
certain people,
gay and lesbian people want to support things so they support gay marriage.
That's fine,
that's all good organized,
do whatever the fuck you want to do,
but the idea that you can get to the actual politicians get special favors.
Yeah.
That's
database to make money.
That's great.
You make money.
That's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
That's,
that's ridiculous.
It should be illegal.
How is that not legal,
but yet insider trading is.
That doesn't make any sense.
That's not illegal,
but not illegal.
I met.
How is that?
Not only was I should've said,
how is that because you're legal and insider trading is illegal.
I mean it's,
it's essentially you're,
it's all stealing.
It's finding all these numbers and pulling them out of the system and sticking
them into your account.
It's like you're doing some crazy shit.
You're influencing the way America runs.
Like literally democracy means freedom.
You're influencing personal freedom for sure,
but how many people are in private prisons right now due to nonviolent drug
offenses that are a direct result of lobbyists pushing for certain things to
remain illegal that is clear,
that is money influencing people's freedom that is literally shifting in degrees
left or to the right,
you know,
as far as plus or minus how many people are incarcerated.
That strikes me,
what you're,
what you're saying strikes me as the most important.
I believe that.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
I think it was James Madison said that special interest groups are,
have always been the threat to this form of system of government.
However,
they'll cancel each other out,
but you know,
it's not happening in the group that has the strongest,
you know,
look at,
look at what organized labor.
I'm part of a union,
so I understand unions,
but some of these,
some of these fucking labor unions are just in.
I was talking to Schwarzenegger about this.
They're,
they're,
they're literally lobbying and they,
and they get it.
They lobby for when they retire after 15,
20 years.
They get 95 percent of their salary or whatever it is for the rest of their
lives.
Now that,
who says,
we can't afford that if bankrupt the state,
they have bankrupt the state.
It's not just,
it's,
it's all different kinds of organized groups of labor who look at the,
look at what the auto united auto workers union did to itself.
You,
you could retire with 95 percent of your pension for the rest of your life and
your whole family had benefits for the rest of their lives.
What are you talking about?
No,
you can't afford.
You couldn't sell enough cars to support your pension plan states the truth.
That's exactly what,
how,
what happened?
The five percent,
95 percent of your salary.
You.
So are you going to go out and look for another job?
Of course not.
And,
and,
and this is exactly what,
what happened with
these big Dildo in their point of view,
they're busting their ass for 20 years making millions of dollars for Chevrolet
the point,
because give me my money,
I couldn't afford it.
They bankrupted the company.
Sons of bitches should have made some better cars to what?
What I was talking about,
what?
They should have thrown all this other shit boxes out and everybody would have
had corvettes just
more cheaper.
Even that their product was so bad and they're making really good products now
is that they can't afford their retirement pool.
So it just,
by the way,
the same thing goes for almost every county in this fucking great state of
California.
California economically looks a lot like grease
and you know,
told me that Arnold Schwarzenegger.
But you know,
I,
I also read that.
I also read that Michael Lewis's book.
We did an exhaustive study on it,
California.
Do you think Michael Lewis gets any pussy?
I was just a cell phone number.
So smart.
Just looking at kind of a cool app from what I eat.
I've seen pictures.
It's kind of like a regular looking,
pretty cool looking dude.
I mean,
yeah,
some people,
some people write huge books and get laid all the time.
That's ridiculous.
I hate them.
Sons of bitches funnier.
You hope you never know.
It's always good to be around people who are.
You're a little in awe of who just are better at supporting to be around people
that are good at shit too.
You know?
Uh,
I did San Francisco and Seattle this past weekend.
We did it with Brian and Greg Fitzsimmons.
Greg Fitzsimmons is fucking funny.
Funny.
He's always been.
He's always been funny,
but he's got this new level of,
I don't give a fuck that,
you know,
I haven't seen from him before.
He,
he took it to the next level this weekend.
He's great.
This past weekend was awesome.
He was really funny in Seattle to do like a half hour.
That's great.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Killer.
It's just like my.
It's like my style of comedy that I enjoy watching.
Just like really ridiculous of rude,
honest,
hilarious,
descriptive.
It was really fun.
It's like,
you know,
like there's certain types of music,
like if you go to a club to see music,
it's never just live music and you take a guess is whether or not it's going to
be hip hop or country western,
but what standup comedy is like?
We don't really have genres,
you know,
you like you could call someone to shop comic,
which is,
you know,
derogatory really to a lot of folks.
But me,
mom,
my favorite comics would be classified in the shock,
comma category.
Like dice clay,
like you call them a shock comic.
I think he creates ridiculous scenarios that are disgusting and Hilarious.
A lot of us think,
but don't say,
uh,
by the blade.
It's a fucking work of art.
Okay.
He's a character.
His name isn't even Andrew dice clay.
He's made a character.
He's,
he does it onstage.
He's got giant glasses on and he says ridiculous shit like that.
You can't just diminish that by calling it shock comedy because to me it's not,
it's a style of comedy.
It's a legit style.
Yeah.
But we don't have labels,
you know,
it's like there's certain types of comedy where,
you and I were talking also about how,
what a privilege it is to feel it to be a headliner and to be somebody who gets
to perform all over the country.
And like sometimes I look at,
I was in Miami,
Fort Lauderdale and I just,
you know,
it was,
I did at one point,
I just had them going pretty strong and I just looked at,
I was like,
I felt like the luckiest human being in the fucking world.
That's why when I watch
at Makani,
he fucking magic mike and his fucking leather chest girdle and it's fucking hot
pants and any and he's coming off say,
hey yoker boy,
come flocking.
Do 10 minutes of stand up.
You fucking idiot.
I don't jump off stage like I just did an hour and a half and crossing somebody
hugged me hard so I can kiss your mouth.
This animosity
attracted him.
Alright.
Expressed.
I hate them.
I mean I hate him.
I hate him.
No,
I was just thinking about how you're.
You're an actor and you have five scenes in a movie and be like,
Whoa.
You were great.
In that movie it,
you collectively are probably doing 10 or 15 minutes of actual activity.
Whereas when you do stand up,
you're out there for.
You know,
it's just a different.
It's just a different thing.
Feels it feels a little.
Why would you care though that he wants to be because
it was a matter what's going on now.
I just saw the movie and I was just.
I was just looking at him going,
you're just,
you took this movie just so you could wear those outfits.
He gave you the biggest boner.
Did he?
He did.
If I was,
if I was gay,
I would definitely.
He's a very attractive one.
Would you choose I Mike channing tatum.
Really?
My boyfriend.
You kidneys got full mouth.
Best genetics.
He's got sick lips.
The eyes out of the cat eyes.
Seems confident too.
He's a great guy.
He's got a big cost sense of humor.
We're both really something Joe Rogan a bronc allocate.
It gets talking about channing tatum cost.
So
that just came out of here.
Here's my bet.
He's got a big truck.
Did you watch the uh,
the actual whole moving because I wanted to annoy myself more and more.
Although I thought the movie was good and I liked it.
I liked,
I liked channing tatum.
I mean I had my hands.
That movie looks so gig channels.
I was flipping through the channels and I saw it popped up and I went whoa.
Change a quick like you know,
how you flipping through like you have previewing next preview at a hotel,
what was checking into a hotel and like I was like,
this is so gay.
I got to get it off.
Like dudes were like gyrating back and forth.
Which by the way,
I think women like that.
I think that motion is really just isolated.
Someone Riding Dick's.
I don't think that.
I know gyrating like the way a guy's doing it.
Women like the rusting they like to get fucked.
They don't.
They want you,
your Dick Riding circled man.
Dick Riding,
sweaty circle.
Connie's too.
And he's got a fucking a leather thong and he's doing back bends and shit and,
and,
but the character I was watching,
what bothered me was I was watching.
I go,
you know,
as an actor,
if I took that role,
there's a lot I do with that role.
May Be,
but I wouldn't because there's not a lot to do.
Like he played it.
Just one note,
shut the fuck up bitch.
She would take that role at a God damn heartbeat tatum and your underwear can be
your boyfriend.
He'd be carrying them around like he was crossing the wedding nuptials.
I would look like I have fucking rickets next to that guy.
So he would do the movie with them though.
Dude,
you would do it.
So shut the fuck up.
Matthew mcconaughey.
A hard time and you're doing the movie.
Maybe he just wanted to meet Jenny channel to
Matthew.
Sorry.
Rather than.
I don't mean to put you down enough guy.
I hear,
I hear.
He's a very nice guy.
Yeah.
Here's a nice car.
Testing me and he's not really vain and not an annoying.
Well listen man,
he's playing a part.
How could you like if you judged me based on the movies?
Zookeeper.
You fucking dance in Malibu.
Who Does?
Yeah.
With the shirt off.
Yay.
Does.
If I see you and you're doing pushups in front of the pavilion in Malibu,
I'm going to take your back.
We're going to take you back and I'm going to get their hooks in my French,
kick him in the ribs.
Just gonna.
Hold it.
He can scream all you want.
You shouldn't have been doing pushups that a lot to do with a knapsack on,
with a knapsack on a Bandana was while tourists take pictures of you,
is that what he was doing?
That annoys me.
He wanted to be really fit for this movie.
Maybe it was like something he was working on,
like what kind of exhibitionist could he become because he was playing a part in
a movie man.
Did you murder?
He look,
think about,
look what,
what,
what's his name does when he does.
Um,
uh,
Daniel Day Lewis,
when he gets immersed in a role,
he's,
I mean,
he's unbelievably immersive.
Maybe that's what Matthew mcconaughey was done.
It was just being a douchebag.
He's playing a Douche bag in the movie man.
And that's douchebag activity at the role was in so much of a Douche bag.
The role was more of a,
just think he's supposed to be the club owner,
but you'll see what I mean.
Would it be okay if he did pushups in a weird place where nobody could say like
say if there was like his.
There was like some grass in front of his car and nobody could see any dropdown
for a quick 15.
Here's what Bob.
It bothers me.
Yes,
there I am.
Here's what bothers me.
If you work out just for the sake of vanity to and then and then it,
I,
when I see what you're doing is just,
you're just sculpting for,
for it to be a peacock.
I,
I understand.
I get,
I get staying in shape.
There's something about it.
If it's not for something functional,
it was not for something like that.
You're doing.
I immediately.
I'm just saying you can do it.
You're not my friend.
That's all I'm saying.
Why is that?
What about a guy who's just doing like bench presses and curls?
Never touches the legs.
Just wants to look good in a tight shirt,
but he,
he's doing it.
You know what you know.
You know why I like that?
Well,
I've got no problem with that.
He's doing it so he can go out and get laid on a Saturday night.
Fucking a bless you.
What do you think Matthew mcconaughey is doing when he's wearing leather
underwear?
Doing that so he can fucking get the dailies and checkoff self.
That's why he's fucking doing it and there's a difference.
I see Matt Maconomy to want a role like that.
Magic Mike All.
I'm seeing something masturbatory.
I watched channing tatum.
He's trying to do something.
He's actually playing a character who's fucking conflicted about being a 30 year
old stripper and it's fucking great.
Makani he is is.
It's a masturbatory performance.
He's watching himself.
He's not trying to do anything.
He's not trying to express anything.
He's trying to play.
I mean,
the guy has shown a pretty broad range of angry in the world of television.
Merriam.
I don't want to marry him,
but it was really good and contact the hell's going on.
It was all right.
He was good in contact.
I enjoyed him.
I thought he was sensitive about that.
Seemed like the type of guy that would fall in love with Jodie foster.
That was a long time ago.
He listened.
I can't believe you just brought that.
He was great.
It's amazing that even after all those years,
they still have such a great body.
He looks,
he looks freak you out.
He looks phenomenal.
I mean,
he's got his hair.
His skin is really youthful hair probably.
Did you probably clues from here on?
Maybe there's a lot that's fake
magic Mike,
but this isn't.
This isn't Makani.
Watch him
because I do.
There's your boy.
He's awesome.
He's got a great sense of humor to
Mike.
Mike has fans watch him dance.
Doing
that dreamboat guy that never came along.
That's
actually the idea.
Like
how do you know my brother?
I'm an entrepreneur.
I manage a few business trying to hit on my system.
Okay.
Good.
Top entrepreneurs.
Super.
Super Entrepreneur.
Either one.
I was hoping
it was pretty funny.
I'm just trying to figure out why women money and a good time.
Just trying to forget about the people who existed in the [inaudible] right?
Are we fighting?
This is our first place.
Wait,
when is he a stripper with a heart of gold because I think that's what's going
on here,
man.
Dude,
is that much.
Is that channing tatum?
I was Joe Rogan.
That was so weird.
I just can't be around your lifestyle.
Am I magic Mike?
Right now talking to you,
am I imagining this might be a great season?
Might be roadhouse is actually an okay movie,
man.
You just turned gay.
Then this whole movie did you just weren't gay or there's.
There's Matt.
Let me see.
Are there is.
Oh my God.
He doesn't kiss me song.
Really.
That's it.
I want to see more.
Uh,
you don't want to know what I have to do for 20.
Oh,
I get it.
You suck a cock show.
That's what really goes on with this kid.
He's about six [inaudible],
two trapping beast of a man played.
He played college football.
Shrink wrapping.
Fucking athletes.
Who the fuck?
Why didn't you watch that?
I don't know what happened to you.
I was robbed on your
calender.
Mrs. Calender to watch.
He's.
He's blaming.
Wow.
Oh,
I might have to get high and watch it,
but I'll probably get really scared.
I'll probably have to get my blankie.
You get a little jealous.
You better be inside of a pussy when you watch it.
Really a time.
I don't have that kind of stamina or desire for.
Well,
that's why I got tricked early on in life,
but I figured it out now I'm fine.
Just beaten off and then going about my business.
So you got to take one of these pills.
Yeah.
What is this stuff?
He took a hot rod.
5,000.
Throw that shit over here and I took one last night when I got home.
What's in it?
I can't read this.
It's something extracted from aunt.
So I guess.
Well I don't know.
Something aunt's maker.
You have hard ons and I maybe just don't know that ants have rock hard boners
the whole time.
Look at this label.
Look at this.
What it is.
I guarantee you there's probably some fucking prescription drugs.
I was going to say just my.
It's marketed towards the gay community.
I heard that.
I bet you could give.
I'm not saying it is,
but if.
What if it was.
Is it possible that you could get viagara like bulk Viagra,
like because they have generic or whatever it's called,
would it modafinil or whatever the fuck.
The actual chemicals that the label is so tiny that you can't even read it.
You can read what the fuck's in there.
There's some kind of prescription thing in their life
that they definitely found that with a athletic supplements that there's been a
lot of athletic tainting where you take some shit and then actually have
steroids in it.
There was some stuff that they used to sell that's illegal now.
That essentially is.
Yeah,
well there was a thing called Mag 10 that I took and holy shit,
it was unbelievably strong and you could get it at GNC.
I was fucking soul strong when I was taking that stuff.
It was amazing.
It was just deck animal or something or I don't know what the fuck it was,
but it was essentially it was an oral steroid.
I mean it had an effect of a steroid and you can get a GNC for a little while.
These have ghb it at GNC.
I remember seeing that shit.
It was in a fridge refrigerator.
That's Hilarious,
but it was the biggest.
I mean it just wouldn't go away.
Like I would mess up and then just to be another boner that had been
masturbating again.
It was just crazy.
That sounds like it's just as good as Viagra watching magic.
No,
it was just a coincidence.
I was,
it was odd that a boner.
Well,
I mean,
the only thing that they could be doing is,
uh,
maybe maybe it has some nitric oxide effect.
I mean,
that's the idea behind a.
like those opens up your m and o two pills.
Capillaries.
He said that gave him crazy boners.
It gives you a bonus that has a very viagra like effect.
What's that?
Those,
a nitric oxide drinks.
You know,
those drinks like eno to explode and shit,
which might be illegal now explode.
Yeah.
Maybe that's it loads.
There was some other stuff called Jack Three Day.
One of those is off the market now.
One of them,
they yanked jacked
dude.
I used to take that stuff before I lifted and I just fucking just start
sweating.
Like immediately your heart's pounding,
sweating or I'm waiting for them to.
I want to.
I want them to block the Myostatin my fuck.
You don't want to do that,
man.
You,
you'll look like that artificial you that they used for your,
uh,
your ad for special.
You holding the mic up my arms and they looked like dean listers be bigger
because more stupid because they're like,
we can't look.
It doesn't make any sense.
Look at your head.
Exactly how the framework for this narrow head.
It's weird when you see people that have like big parts of their bodies and then
everything else was normal.
Brennan shops a little bit like that.
Like Brendan's got a small,
like,
like he's got a headline
for that fits on me and he's 65 to 50 and I was looking at his head.
I go,
dude,
you have a fucking.
His hands and his head are not very big.
What did he say?
He,
yeah,
he was like,
I know.
I've got a small fucking head and I got to smile.
I've got small hands.
I was like,
because the rest of his body is retarded.
Like he's so fucking strong.
It's weird when people get looked at the worst,
the biggest head when you have a big head and a little bond.
He said the worst.
A lot of starters.
A lot of stars have that big of little bottles.
Yeah.
Mick Jagger and shit.
He had a big,
huge head,
giant head.
He's 130 pounds,
but your head keeps growing.
Keeps growing,
keeps growing.
That's the weirdest thing that you see old people when they have gigantic ears.
It was like,
Whoa,
what is going on with your ears?
Man knows a large nose though for some reason is not as disturbing because some
people like from the get go,
they have a large nose.
It's just to.
No,
it's a masculine trait to the ears though.
It's like,
what is happening to your ears?
Can you.
Can you stop those with your guards?
Because that shit is worse.
Can you bind your ears?
What if you're an old dude with cauliflower ear?
I mean,
it looks like a Jean labelle.
He ever seen.
Both sides are so big at the sun.
Never hits his face.
I was like,
what the fuck is with those ears?
He's got a giant.
He's got a giant head.
He's 80.
He's an older gentleman.
I wouldn't want him to get me in a fucking double risk law.
Yeah,
we had 80.
He'll break your fucking.
There was a story with some kids breaking into a car in this neighborhood just
fucking 10 years ago or whatever when he's 70 years old and he went out to stop
them and they gave him a hard time.
We put one of them,
the sleep,
the other one who flips on his head.
He's no joke,
dude.
Now certain old men who can't fuck with man.
I didn't fuck with him when he was young and he was.
He was a stunt guy on my on death valley,
the TV show I did and I'm sitting in,
I'm in the makeup chair.
I'm pontificating about fighting like I liked fucking makeup,
chipping the belt in Jujitsu.
I'm talking about.
I got.
Well the guy that's going to beat him in this UFC fight and I'm like going on
and on and basically Joe Rogan lightened the fucking trailer.
Right.
But I don't know as much and I'm like fucking being a fucking you.
If you'd heard me talk a little bit like this is going to fight in the octagon,
you know,
little knowledge goes a long way.
Fucking gene.
The bell starts piping in,
but he's got Zombie makeup on and I go,
you seem to know fighting a little bit and,
and the mangoes says Sheila Bell,
Bro.
And I go,
Holy Shit,
Mr Bell.
So sorry I haven't talked about fighting this whole time.
And I spent,
I was glued to his side for three days,
a little puppy.
Puppy dog asked him questions and everything and he's a sweetheart of a guy too.
He judges does a lot of judging here.
You see him at a MMA events and he's always with Ronda Rousey,
you know,
he's a.
He worked a lot of those guys that she worked out with him or something.
Well,
he worked with,
I'm sure the sheer.
He's done some work with her.
He's worked with a lot of those.
The Armenian dudes go cars guys.
Like there's what?
A group of fucking animals are they?
Oh yeah.
Car Row strong shit.
Cairo Cairo's.
Ridiculous.
Strong.
Karl Pribram was back when,
I think it was a blue belt or a purple belt and just ragdolled
me.
Really?
Yeah.
He throwed me around.
He's strongly shit.
Well,
you know,
Caro beat,
so could you in a fucking judo match when he was a kid,
so could you.
Is so much bigger than Carl.
And they had an open way.
Judo match and Carl beat up.
That's weird.
Strong that way.
Carl was a super talented a judo too.
He had a real bad injury though when he was training for the Matt.
He fine,
you know,
Carl was a.
had a bunch of.
He's another dude that had not budget per prescription pill problems.
And what happened was he tore his leg when he was training for a title shot back
when Matt Hughes was champion and he tore it bad.
He flexes it when he flexes it.
Now it looks like a shark.
Took a bite out of his leg and I'm not exaggerating,
his hamstring just disappeared.
Exploded.
And he never got it surgically repaired.
So he's got this big concave area and his leg and it took most of the power out
of his leg and he got him on pain pills.
So I that,
that guy health insurance.
Well,
I mean I don't know what it was and I'm sure that's.
Yeah,
I'm sure he didn't have health insurance or maybe tried to like rehab it.
I'm pretty sure he didn't have insurance.
So you know,
now I don't know if there's anything they can do about it.
I think once the muscle like slides back and rolls up,
I think it's really hard to reattach it.
I think they have to do it right after the injury.
I know that's the case with biceps.
Like a lot of dudes,
they blow their bicep out and then they have like no bicep if you seen that
before.
Yes.
A lot of fighters have that where it curls up and it's like the top of their
bicep was like a little knot and then below it there's nothing left.
Yeah,
that's what it's like with his leg.
So it kind of fucked his career up.
You know when you're making your living off your body.
Well then the other thing about training,
you know,
as you get older and a lot of guys were training a long time that you want to go
in and blow yourself to bits in the gym.
Actually what happens is by the time you're 40,
a lot of times you're,
you're having major problems with your hips or your knees and stuff like that.
So a huge part of exercise is knowing when to stop and doing just enough a body.
If you look at people's bodies like athletes and stuff,
you realize no matter how strong they are,
we are fucking fragile man.
Bone and cartilage doesn't really do well under duress.
Yeah,
well there's certain parts of your body that break,
you know,
there was nothing he could do about it.
And they hips,
hips,
ankles,
you know,
certain shit that just breaks down.
Man.
I see a lot of people with hip surgery.
Man,
that's scary.
Fucking shit.
Hip Surgery Sucks because when you get a fake hip,
it's good for 10 years.
That's ridiculous.
And you're not doing sports anymore.
And by the way,
if they come out with some shit that grows you a better hip joint,
now you can't do it anymore because you've hacked your shit off and put an
artificial one in there.
Well,
they're going to have artificial bones.
Artificial ever.
I mean,
haven't they already replaced like femurs and stuff or.
I don't know if it was a Femur,
but I believe they,
they've replaced part.
Maybe it.
What's the Big One?
There's a fibia and that there are a number of people who have,
who have rebuilt.
Literally they trachea's and bladders.
They take the cartilage from a cadaver and then they sponsor
cricket.
Cricket,
Yeah.
That's funny.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Let me to try find.
I'll try.
I won't find it.
Bridal tell you.
Well it was.
I was in the desert.
As soon as you get up,
you stopped some real hamburger and let it go rank.
Um,
but uh,
what was I talking about?
Something really important.
What were you talking about?
Like it now you're looking for it and it shot 20 cricket
injuries.
The body they take,
they took a trachea as women had a tricky.
I had to be removed because of tuberculosis,
and then they took a trachea from a cadaver and they sprayed it with her stem
cells and she grew a trachea and now she has it in her body.
What happens is,
I believe that the cartilage then is taken over by the stem cells and they grow
their own cartilage.
So yeah,
she grew her own tracheas.
That's incredible.
And they did the same thing with the bladders.
Well,
you know,
when you grow,
when you have an acl surgery and you use a cadaver acl graft,
it basically just acts as a scaffold and right.
And then your body develops to build over it,
a real acl over it.
So as you do your rehab and your exercises,
your body is assimilating that,
that tissue and taking over with its own.
Right.
So in the first,
you know,
in the beginning it's just like,
it's not really wanting to grow new scaffolding stuff,
new fucking legs for people that lose their fucking land.
People think that it was replaced.
They think,
well,
now I got this new ligament,
it's in place.
And uh,
you know,
I just got to strengthen it like,
no,
no.
It's like,
it's got to grow.
There will have to talk about his acl,
you know,
you,
you feel 100 percent.
But the,
he didn't do it that way.
He did a different thing.
He did what's called a Patella tendon graft and that I did on my left leg.
And what that is,
you know that tendon in the front of your knee,
and this is one of the arguments for doing this.
The tenant in front of your knee is really big.
It's really fat.
You don't need all of it.
So they take like a third of it and they have a piece of bone from your Shin
where it attaches and a piece of bone from your knee cap where it attaches
there.
And then they open you up like a fish and then they screw it into the bottom of
your leg.
They screwed into the top,
scrolling,
scrolling through the bone into your.
They drill a hole in your leg and then they screw the bone into place.
I have screws in the bottom of my knee and in the top of my knee and the left
side that show up and x rays to amazing.
Yeah.
And then it's just a matter of getting circulation to that tissue and letting
that tissue heal up.
And he was talking about,
he said he had to wait for a circulation of capital or is it,
it's a use a long process.
And you also have to make sure that during that process you don't reinjury
yourself because you still essentially have no acl on that side.
This is wobbly piece of flesh.
When was the last time he fought George?
It's been awhile.
He,
uh,
he injured his leg at least nine months ago.
And uh,
you know,
he's,
he's ready for November and
know
a performance enhancing drug.
I know it's an important test.
Positive for weed man.
He tested po man.
He didn't listen,
man.
Fucking Po,
Po is on his ass.
He tested positive for a marijuana metabolite,
which is non psychoactive.
So what he had in his system,
like say if he only took this marijuana metabolite,
like took it into pill form,
it wouldn't do anything.
It does.
It literally is non psychoactive.
You can't get high from it.
So the idea of marijuana as a performance enhancing drug with this non
psychoactive trace element inside your body,
it's just silly because he wasn't in.
It's one thing is if he tested that he was tested,
that he was high when he was fighting.
Okay.
And by the way,
that has happened when he fought Gomi,
they did a test.
I don't know if he was actually high when he fought gummy,
but he probably got high of the day before.
Amazing.
Fucking great.
That was a great fight to going in that Gogo blog.
Oh,
that was so sweet.
He was like,
he's so calm under fire,
man.
He,
he sets that shit up and slapped it on me.
That was a.
That was a big,
big victory.
That was some anger.
But that controlled anger,
like somehow he can keep it.
The thing is about is pace.
Nick Diaz has this crazy pace that he can keep going,
so other dudes like as you were in this wild dog fight with him,
they were out and he just keeps going.
Well that's kind of why I'd like to see it.
Cain Valasquez fight fucking John Jones.
Well,
Keynes gonna Fight Junior.
Dos Santos.
That's the next one.
Start the first time,
right?
Yes,
he did.
They're fighting in July.
The better boxer.
Well,
well I dunno when Jr Kratos and it's just what it is.
I mean they said that junior had a knee injury.
Cane definitely had a knee injury.
They fall on Fox and know cain stood up with them a little bit too long and
junior just winged the bomb.
Adam and caught him right in the town wearing gloves and those guys.
When you guys guys who hit that hard,
I don't care what your head looks like.
You're going out.
Yeah.
Well Junior,
junior punches fucking hard.
You know,
he punches hard and he swung that one.
They're fighting again.
January the January first weekend.
I think it's December 29th.
The big event in Vegas.
It should be fucking crazy.
And that's the rematch because everybody thought before that fight,
the junior dos Santos was going to be,
you know,
a top fighter,
they,
they definitely thought that he had a chance of winning that fight.
But king was the favorite,
you know,
Cain was the guy that everybody felt like after he destroyed brock Lesnar,
every Goddamn Cain Velasquez might be the best ever.
What a fucking heavyweight destroyer.
But junior just changed the whole course of the heavyweight title picture with
one punch,
you know.
And now everybody's scared of junior.
He's so hard to take down.
His hands are so good.
Didn't he?
Didn't,
he?
Uh,
he took care of a Carl and as well,
right?
It'd beat the fuck other Shankar one man.
Shane when took that fight to coming off of injuries chain has had a succession
of injuries,
mostly related to electrical engineer.
Super Nice Guy.
Super Smart Couples.
SMART,
great guy.
He's strong,
strong.
He picked me up in a bear hug and started squeezing me and Andy and I.
and I was like,
because I always fuck with them,
I'm grabbing them.
I'm like,
I'll fucking,
I'm dragging and pepper your ribs or whatever.
I'm always,
he's such a giant.
We tried to arm wrestle.
He picks me up,
he starts squeezing me and I started immediately tapping and he goes,
that's 40 percent bro.
And I look at nate markers right there.
And I go,
could he do that to you?
And it goes,
if I let him,
yes.
He goes,
yeah,
he's a spooky dude.
He's got some serious strength.
He had a long series of injuries that he got from football.
Quite a few.
And he's had some surgeries to sort of clear up some of the issues,
but when that stuff starts fucking with you,
man,
you know,
especially back in nerve issues.
He's had a lot of that.
That yeah.
Well I think he's probably smart to keep that full time job,
you know?
I mean he likes working till he says it separates.
His family likes work and he says it's the work sort of separates him from the
gym time and let them to completely relax and get into his work.
And he allows him not to dwell on it,
like some fighters just have the whole data themselves.
You said he's got such a good sense of humor.
I did little guest spot on on the ultimate fighter and I came in at one point I
had,
when I first met him,
I go,
fuck.
I don't know what I do.
Like what would I do with you if you were my roommate in prison?
Like what would I.
What would I do against you?
And he goes,
you'd suck my cock with those eyes.
He just did nothing blinking.
He just looked at him.
You'd suck my cock.
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
Yes.
I was trying to talk him out of it.
I'd have to figure out a way to make a six foot one,
285 pound fighter my tight.
Just talk them out of it.
Yeah,
just sucking cock.
How bad your breath smells.
Exactly.
Yeah.
What if you just took a pool in your hand and rubbed it all over your mouth?
Still want some of this?
What I would do,
bitch,
you want me to suck you?
Would you rather eat or suck her?
Suck Shane Collins.
Dick.
Well,
you probably use the celebrity.
Probably healthier to suck his dick.
Think of like eating poo is really dangerous,
but hepatitis from one and just,
you know,
a Shitty,
shitty self esteem from the O'brian.
We're going to have to hire someone to kill that fucking crooked.
I'll just bring my cat over here.
You calves not good enough with that cricket.
The cricket is a gangster.
He's a Pasadena cricket.
Don't make fake noises to fuck.
She make you feel like you guys are camping again?
No.
There was no bugs too cold for bugs,
man.
Yeah.
There was no bugs at all.
We were out in the middle of nowhere.
We go to.
I was thinking about this.
If we go in August to Alaska and hunted Caribou.
What about grizzly bears?
I don't find possibility.
They encountered,
um,
this last.
They went hunting with Tim Ferris,
who by the way was returning to the podcast,
I believe on the 18th powerful Tim Ferriss podcast.
He's not available.
He's doing mine though.
And the 18th.
Sorry.
It's only about Brian's going to bring it back.
Get
back in.
Your Day.
Went in August.
They when a Caribou hunting,
he went with Rinella and they shot a Caribou,
but apparently they had a chase grizzly bears out of camp because the care.
Yeah,
because what was happening was the Caribou,
they,
you find them when they run in these big herds.
Okay.
You go out and stock when you find them.
Well,
there's camp grounds and some of the Caribou had gone through the places where
people were camping.
So the folks that were there before them had shot Caribou in that camp grounds
in the campground smelled like butchered flesh.
Fuck.
They had gut piles.
They had animals hanging from me.
So when they got there that night,
the grizzly bears came.
So they had a scare him off.
They had a run at them and shoot at him.
Jesus.
Yes.
I don't like that.
That's one of the first things that I talked about.
Dog Fuck that before we were so apprehensive about this trip,
both Brian and I were both like fucking what about bears duty?
Worried about bears?
Yes,
I called him up,
he was,
I was just fucking thinking about bears because as it got down to like the last
couple of weeks we were like,
we're really going to go camping with these crazy animals and the middle of
nowhere.
No,
you're in a tent and you can't protect yourself.
You can't see a common.
Especially for the first night was freezing rain.
The first night was 35 degrees outside and we were sleeping in.
It's pouring rain and twelfth grades on that boat on a canoe for four hours.
I had,
I was literally wearing a sleeping bag.
I was fucking cold.
It was cold as shit.
But uh,
I,
I'll use it as an exercise.
The rowing part,
I just rode as hard as I could use it as a workout.
And then the hiking,
I just thought of,
you know,
control my breathing and use the hiking is just moving up.
There's no promise promise when you weren't moving,
you know,
I almost did a workout the day before we left.
I was sitting around the house.
I was packing up all my shit.
I was like,
maybe I should just go lift to do a crazy kettlebell workout or something.
If I did that,
I would have been so fucked.
I had no idea it was going to be so physically demanding.
Those guys have.
You have to be in serious shit canoeing and then you're hiking and you got to
pack on your back of pack in that meat out pack,
net 45 pounds of meat or whatever it was.
That was not easy and we only had to walk a mile.
He talked about an elk that they shot where they had.
They got up for four days in a row.
They got up before it was light and they got back when it was dark out and all
they did was caught and pack this fucking animal.
Bring.
It was so bad that you were looking for nine miles out of yourself or something.
You know?
They walk nine miles both ways everyday,
so they walked 18 miles and brought back,
meet every day over the hills and craggy bluffs.
Is that a real thing?
Sounds good.
Dry Creek road.
The sre with all sorts of following them as they went left into the right at the
show.
I got his.
By the way,
when are you gonna you have to listen to just,
if you get a chance.
We're posting it.
I don't know why I'm thinking about this.
Are you advertising when your podcasts?
I swear to God.
I'll shut your fucking life because you're going like this.
You're going and you're talking about for some reason character.
And he used to do a Mike Tyson.
And uh,
we do.
Uh,
we do a little interview with Mike Tyson.
I'm a 10 minute podcast.
You might want to check it out.
Who you interview actually interviewed him.
What'd you catch them?
Don't worry about it.
Just fucking listen to it.
It's only 10 minutes.
Oh,
it's will sasso doing a Mike Tyson.
I don't do that to me.
You fucking lying to me.
I looked in your eyes.
I saw deception.
I'm not a girl,
Brian.
I was like,
oh,
I can't do this to me.
Trying to advertise your podcasts and you figure in the way
that you really had Mike Tyson,
but you didn't get son of a bitch.
Fucking impressionists used to do Mike Tyson.
Can you do it?
It's not that good.
It's pretty good.
I'd have to listen to them talk.
If I listen to him talk,
you could do it.
I can,
I can imitate people.
Want to hear them talk a bunch of times,
but I don't practice like,
I'm not like,
I'm not like a real impressionist.
Like,
like they had a.
and Anthony had was his face.
So that was talking about earlier.
Uh,
Kevin Pollack,
who's brilliant,
his fucking impressions are ridiculous.
Like have you heard is Christopher Walken?
That thing just popped and nobody would know.
I don't know what's going on.
You might have to take this bitch apart.
We've gotten,
got electrical problems.
So the government scanning equipment interfering with our fucking microphones.
Those sons of bitches,
right?
Your own Dick Jokes.
Feds.
Gumshoe strange.
Yeah.
It's funny that we think the government listening to us when they could just
download it on the Internet.
That's how stupid we are.
They're spying on the show like this.
If the kid just.
They're getting it before it's on.
USTREAM is not.
There's not enough fucking people guys have a computer.
This elections close.
Is he looking at the fucking tweets and stuff now?
It's almost half and half.
It seems like.
Of course.
That's what makes the fucking.
That's what makes the plot sounds better.
It makes the give it more drama.
Even while they're both working for the same people.
Actually there's a lot more romney than I thought.
Well,
white people are mad.
When we were in Montana,
we actually encountered a douchebag at a restaurant.
There was a like berating us,
you know about Obama as if he knew we were voting for Obama.
It wasn't just that he wanted us to vote for Romney.
He was going to intimidate us.
He was such a fucking yogurt.
Yeah.
He was like,
it was really funny when you go.
It was a cool little diner.
It was too bad.
This guy ruined the experience by being the owner because the waitress was real
nice.
The food was great and we're sitting there.
God put him in his place though.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was.
It was interesting.
We were still dirty from the road.
Okay.
We had hadn't shaved.
We hadn't washed.
We hadn't bathed in five days and we were driving from the river to billings,
which is about two and a half hours and we stopped and got some food at this
diner in the middle of fucking nowhere and
walks up and goes,
you ain't voting for Obama?
Yeah,
he killed two of my boys.
I was like,
now I am yet two of my boys that we.
They got to have a to of mine seal team and he had a marine hat on,
had a shrine in the marines.
He never did a day in combat.
You can see those guys.
You're like,
oh you.
You were the guy who who fucking fake an injury when all the other guys were
going out and that's what I think.
Who knows what he did that might've been a smart move.
Faking injuries given that much.
My fucking put a desk.
Romney's that projected winner in Georgia.
That's shocking,
is a really hot land.
A lot of white people in Georgia,
dude,
don't kill yourself,
don't kid yourself.
George has got some money to Atlanta specialist.
It's kind of calmed down there now and there are a lot of black professionals in
Atlanta,
like it's really interesting to kind of a cool thing to see.
Like the hotel I'm staying at his,
you know,
all,
like just kind of mostly professional black people and,
and uh,
it's,
uh,
there was a lot of,
I think a lot of middle class,
upper class black people went down to it and let Atlanta because there was,
the economy was there and stuff for them at the time.
And it's pretty cool,
man.
It's a,
it's a,
it looks like a town primarily.
You see a lot of black people in positions of authority and,
and uh,
and the movie I'm doing right now is all that and it's really refreshing,
man.
It's kind of a cool idea.
I haven't seen it.
You see that more in Atlanta than anywhere.
Atlanta is a very fascinating in that way.
It's,
you know,
to,
to be a young black person in this country.
And look for role models,
it's got to be unbelievably hard,
you know,
and to see like a guy like Obama get into office and have everybody's so fucking
mad at them and everybody,
like all these white people just having said that though,
the people that did elect him,
we're at where white people.
Sure.
No,
I mean I voted for him.
Yeah,
like right people read books.
But the white people don't read books.
Those white people hate him.
It's interesting when they listened to like,
I'm not saying that Obama was a saint and I'm not saying that I'm a supporter
because I certainly wasn't supportive before he got into office.
But then I think I liked them as a human being.
Like when I listened to him talk,
it doesn't sound good Dick Guy.
I liked him because he strikes me as eminently sensible.
I don't think the socialist,
the one thing he said,
he said,
what is the one thing we don't know about you?
And he said,
I believe the free enterprise system is the most important,
uh,
you know,
something to the effect of it's the most important thing for a high standard
you're living.
He said there's but,
but,
but with,
with checks and balances.
And so I think he's,
I don't think he is this far left guy.
I actually think he's very much in the middle in a very sensible guy.
And I think the more I read about his policies,
I happen to agree with his foreign policy,
visa vi Iran and other places more than I do with Rami.
I just think he's more reasonable.
Man.
He's a very smart guy.
But the issue is that I can't really,
I don't really see him being able to do what anybody.
I don't think there's any one person that has any real say,
oh,
there never has been in our government.
You're not supposed to,
but I know what you're saying.
But I'm saying it's like all the different things that he wanted to do before he
got into office,
closed Guantanamo Bay,
you know when he said he would veto the NDA,
the all the different things.
It's so blatantly obvious that the position is not what we envisioned.
That was when we were kids.
We thought of being the president and this is one guy who was going to figure it
all out.
Everybody get in line,
we're going to do this the right way,
and he leads us to victory like this.
This system is a fucking complicated.
Just know maybe what you said.
What you said is that the biggest thing is most people don't feel represented.
It's like you know,
you,
you feel like if you vote for Romney or you vote for Obama is not going to make
that much of a difference because you're kind of voting for the same guy in some
way.
Yeah.
The that moved into the position of power that is clearly stronger and more
influential than the people can have a big,
big effect on who gets elected to the supreme court and socially they have
an impact on an agenda.
Right.
So,
and I have,
I actually think that Romney in Obama's foreign policy or different enough,
I think that romney is rattling his sword in Iran.
You know?
I don't know.
I just don't agree with.
I don't think anybody who's a governor could ever possibly know what it's like
to be a president at the same way when Obama was running for office and he said
he would do this about Afghanistan and mccain went,
Whoa,
whoa.
Like you don't you know,
you,
you can't say this is some shit.
When Mccain and Romney and Obama were campaigning where it was clearly
campaigning talk,
it was clearly like speeches,
but there was a moment when Obama was talking about Afghanistan and Mccain went
like,
you don't even know what you're talking about.
Like you're describing an area that hasn't changed much since the time of
Alexander the Great,
like this idea that you're going to go in there and just take over the land.
Like you're,
that's crazy.
Talk like,
you know,
and Mccain,
the way he did it,
it was like,
Whoa,
son.
It was like,
this was a serious topic.
All that fucking campaign and bullshit aside.
Like,
you're,
you're talking about what I did for a living.
You're talking crazy.
Like you don't know what the with it's what happens to presidents
realizing it.
Certainly I got that impression from,
from our scenario where,
you know,
the impression I got from him,
what he's saying is that you don't have any power.
I mean,
you,
you can set an agenda and you can veto things,
but at the end of the day,
you're not doing much without congress.
If anything.
Uh,
and,
and by the way,
you're dealing with a lot of different,
you know,
a vested interest
in the congressional choices coming up this,
this election,
it might be more important even than what's going on with residents because
there's so much fucking waste and so many dumb people that have gotten into
elected offices.
There's so much bullshit there and slowly but surely it gets exposed,
but it's still the key problem never gets addressed.
The key problem of special interest groups and funny money there that none of
that stuff gets addressed.
So it all stays.
Question also becomes this
though,
you know,
if,
if indeed you have special interest in,
you're always going to have smart people that figure out a way to manipulate the
machine.
Yeah.
Then then then is the answer to make the machine less influential?
Meaning do you make the machine smaller?
That may be the only way to do it.
I think that's kind of the conservative argument,
but that's the real conservative argument.
Real conservative.
But when you say the word conserve you though,
well,
I don't want queers getting married.
That's the first thing that people think.
I think
I'm not,
I'm not a,
I,
I am.
When I say conservative,
I just believe that the state shouldn't be involved in who I choose to marry,
whether it's channing tatum,
matthew,
or,
you know,
a girl.
Sorry,
I use those.
Sorry.
Uh,
you know,
or,
or the fact that I can't get,
I can't smoke cannabis.
I'm not saying I'm going to get into a car and drive to tons of fast moving
steel if I get caught.
There are laws for that but,
but let me make my own choices and my own mistakes,
you know?
And then when I say conservative,
I mean I think I'm just talking about being fiscally conservative.
I think I'm talking about not spending what we don't make.
I lived that way myself.
I don't know why the government can't.
It,
it's,
I don't know why.
I always have to get why.
The minute I'm at a dinner party in Los Angeles and I started talking about
small government or,
or a conservative idea,
I get labeled immediately as somebody who is against gay marriage against
abortion.
No,
well you're racist.
Yeah,
I reject.
I reject a lot of the republican platform in that sense because it's just as
controlling as the other side.
What about a woman's right to choose Brian?
I believe in it.
What if you called it killing babies?
This is the killing babycenter.
Well,
that's fine,
but the problem is we put a price on human life all the time.
If you want to save lives,
how come you're not out petitioning to make the speed limit on the,
on the highway 30 miles an hour.
It'll,
it'll fucking save lives.
You know why we don't do that because it would be grossly inconvenient and it
would stall the economy and our standard of living.
So guess what?
We do put a price on human life all the time.
And I happen to believe that if a woman's for harboring a life,
you can biologically make the case that it is murder because it's a life.
It just happens to be on life support.
Uh,
that's fine.
I,
I still,
I still think a woman's choice to make,
to do with her body what she chooses is paramount over that.
It's not consistent with the Judaeo Christian ethic,
but that's.
I don't go to church.
Yeah.
But what,
do you have those times?
Do you have a timeline where you think it's a very good question?
I've,
I've kind of tried to avoid this very,
very complicated question,
but we do have timelines.
First of all,
right?
For the most part,
after the third trimester,
it becomes very dangerous for the woman and 48 days in this one,
the whatever religion thought the,
uh,
the soul entered the body.
Well,
the Hindus,
well,
if you,
let's take,
let's take a couple of ethical arguments about it.
So let's take up severely,
severely retarded human being.
Somebody who can't feed themselves,
somebody who can't even breathe on their own.
Um,
and if you were to kill that person,
if I were to go into some other,
that person with a pillow,
even though they don't have any feeling and parts they can't communicate,
then then what would happen is I'd go to jail for murder.
You take a fetus that is not yet even developed with its hands ahead,
however reacts to pain.
We know it is on its way to becoming a human being and in a lot of aspects of
the human being,
just a severely underdeveloped human being.
It's,
it's a very similar thing to kill that.
That very small creature that is living,
that does respond to stimuli does it,
does respond to pain and continues to do so and more and more of a what we would
consider independent human fashion.
That is that not why is that not murder?
That would be where the argument is.
It's very hard to actually get out of that argument.
It's very hard.
It's why I have a lot of respect for the notion that people who say religiously,
I believe it's murder.
I have to,
I have to be pro pro life.
I,
I do respect that because you could make a very strong biological argument that,
that human being is just as human as you are in a lot of ways.
You just have to be independent,
more independent.
Uh,
you're not relying on a human being to keep you alive.
Well,
we're never going to figure out how to fix that until we figured out how to fix
the dirty trick of fucking equals making people that is a dirty God damn trick
that we need to address.
Well,
because it's so.
I have this
unbelievable desire to fuck but yet fucking makes people.
And you can fuck when you're like 13,
but we don't have to run from Jaguars everyday when we know we're not getting
chased down by crocodiles.
We don't need this many people.
Well,
not only do you not need this many people,
as my other argument for being pro choice and is,
is that you're going to take care of that kid.
You're going to take care of that child who just got pregnant by,
by,
by a woman who has no money.
Who doesn't want that baby?
She can't take care of it.
Are you going to or you can have another ward of the state or somebody who
doesn't get any attention or somebody doesn't have any resources.
We've got to separate the fact that fucking makes a.
makes a person.
You're getting crazy.
We've got to get to the heart of this.
We gotta we gotta figure out a way.
So you make a person through a very complicated process.
What about birth control?
Well,
that could fuck up your body.
You know,
for women,
they take pills that essentially trick their body and thinking they're pregnant
all the time.
That can't be good.
Yeah.
That condoms also real real and everything.
Gross,
disgusting things such stupid thing.
Tomorrow I'm having that Peter Duesberg guy on the podcast.
He's the guy that believes that a HIV doesn't cause aids.
It's all people that are doing drugs.
He said this,
it's really almost untenable.
Science would be like,
wow.
Yeah,
well that's why I'm interested to see how he,
how you,
you know,
figures that end to.
The problem is that they're not doing drugs and there wasting away of HIV.
So I think the Africa thing though,
apparently they're not even getting tested for HIV,
they're there,
they have aids and that could be a variety of things including poor nutrition.
I think that's the argument there is that the actual testing and this guy is
ignoring a lot of the data on that.
We're gonna find out,
I don't know,
like you want to do it with me going to do it when really tomorrow,
tomorrow at 3:00 here.
Yeah.
Um,
I'd like to come and listen to them but to 2:00,
2:00,
come and listen.
Please do come and listen to and sit in.
Right?
You too,
please.
All right.
I mean who knows,
cause my,
this is just uh,
look,
I,
I read about this guy's position a long time ago and I thought it was
fascinating.
I've read a bunch of articles,
but what bothers me about a guy like this is very simple and I'll bring it up to
them.
I watched a lot of people die in New York.
I watched them have it with my own eyes without medication.
This is before they had magic medication.
This is one where they had,
they had act and I watched them all dot.
Yeah,
that was one of the main and I watched him die in a very humiliating and a very
terrible way.
Do you know that act is a cancer medication that they stopped giving the chemo
patients because it was killing them quicker than not having.
Well,
I don't know,
but I do know that a lot of these people went the alternative route and
everything else.
I know a couple of people that stopped doing it and then along came a guy I
believe by the name of David Ho who was a scientist who was man of the year Time
Magazine's man of the year who invented a little something called protease
inhibitors.
Protease inhibitors make the cell wall the the I guess the helper t cell,
very slick.
They covered coated with a teflon so that the virus cannot latch onto that sail.
It's gooey and so what happens is with protease inhibitors now you have people
who are HIV positive and used to be a death sentence.
Right?
I can remember it like it was yesterday and I watched it happen and now you get
people who are HIV positive.
I know several who treat it like it's diabetes and in fact now when you get HIV,
a lot of doctors will say,
hey,
good news.
This could be diabetes,
will keep you alive for the next 30 years on protease inhibitors.
That's a miracle.
These people that got HIV,
do any of them engage in illicit drug use?
Some of them do.
Some of them.
I believe.
What duesberg point is that the only reason why the HIV wasn't fought off by
their immune system was that their immune system was destroyed by the use of
drugs,
meth,
emile nitrates,
bunch of different things.
I'm going to ask him about why wanting rica is talks about and the bulk of the
science is that the reason that it never became a white European disease.
Why?
Why didn't white men,
straight men get it,
but a lot of them got in Africa.
Why was it a heterosexual disease in Africa?
Why was it not a heterosexual disease in the Middle East and in Europe and in
America?
Why?
Well,
they just isolated a gene that you,
if you are of northern European,
Middle Eastern,
north African heritage,
you have a gene that saved you from the black plagues of that hit Europe enroll
to all,
all the Fertile Crescent.
You have a gene.
I can't remember the name of the gene.
That gene makes you very resistant to the HIV virus to contracting it through
regular sex.
The only straight men for the most part,
if you look at the army statistics and stuff,
who ca who got HIV were guys who were intravenous drug users using infected
needles and they were putting it into directly into their bloodstream.
The gay men that survived the epidemic.
We're men who are doing the fucking not getting fucked.
Those were the men that survived the epidemic because it was a.
let me tell you,
it aids in the eighties and the early nineties devastated the gay community,
devastated it.
It was a war zone.
I walked those men walk around.
I've watched listening.
What you're saying,
you're essentially supporting this guy's theory.
No,
I'm not saying that the people that got at world intravenous drug users.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that to get to get to get you.
You ain't mainly intruded with the people that were very.
They're very resilient physically because they had excellent genes that they've
gotten from surviving from the black plague.
The black plague.
Yes,
but it would be very strong unless.
Unless you were getting.
You were getting injected into your body directly through the semen,
through your anus or or through.
Yes,
I did because I just think it's funny that I'm saying I sound like a scientist,
so I'm so,
so about this guy who was the University of California biologist,
a tenured professor.
Why would he he not know this that you're telling what your title.
I don't know if he knows it,
but I'm going to bring it up to him and the other thing that I'm going to ask
Duesberg as this,
hey,
how come the majority of scientists all over the world and all the money that
goes into these protease inhibitors,
protease inhibitors,
work,
they seem to work and why are people staying alive when I remember them dying?
Well,
what's in that tool?
Let's let him let him answer.
Those were fucking proposing seems every time I meet with these guys,
they're the only guy I've every other scientists must be,
you know,
I don't know.
Have you ever looked up like how many scientists don't believe HIV causes AIDS?
Because.
Let's go with that right now.
Let's take a guest.
Seven.
Okay.
How many scientists to this?
I just know that the credible,
credible journalists and people who really follow this stuff.
I'm including people like Clinton and and like that.
Clinton.
Yeah.
Bill Clinton and Linda did a lot of work for AIDS in Africa.
A great deal of sort of George go over there and fuck up a storm water to be all
dirty,
slick willie.
I'm going to help you out.
Will you go to a aids and how many scientists don't believe HIV causes aids and
it's Duesberg on aids article in spin.
That's the first fucking thing that comes up.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
I don't really.
My Endo an HIV and aids,
I have a feeling my room would be a lot fuller.
Kary Mullis
hm.
I think.
Hm.
Either way if you get HIV,
it's a very serious diagnosis.
This is what Carrie.
Carrie Moss is a,
a Nobel prize winning scientist and uh,
he's um,
he's also always an Lsd user.
He created a,
the invention of PCR test.
You know,
he won the prize for chemistry and a crazy smart people out there.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But what he says is everyone in the field knows that there's at least some
dissension over whether there's evidence that HIV is the probable cause of aids.
There somewhere in the literature that there scientific evidence presented that
HIV is the probable cause of aids.
And if there is,
where is it?
Who should be attributed with the scientific evidence supporting that statement.
HIV is a probable cause of a tasting.
This guy,
the fact that he just said that,
if that's,
if that's what you did,
say.
Okay.
By the way,
stop.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
Stop.
Nineteen 94.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
I was like,
I had to scroll up to the top.
We're going to shit all over the guy looking at it like I already figured it,
but meanwhile he's dead.
He's like,
he can't even defend himself.
Does HIV really cause aids if you just.
Google does HIV.
Really it and most people think that argument's been put to put to rest in 2012.
Well,
yeah.
This is 1994.
It seems like a lot of people had some questions about it.
I'll make their names.
I remember somebody they thought age was in mosquitoes.
It was about the same time period isn't somebody will make their name by
basically being controversial.
Well,
I'm,
I'm curious,
cynical,
but I'm curious if there's any,
anything that he's going to say that's gonna Rattle that opinion of yours.
Uh,
obviously this guy has,
he's been pushing this for a long,
long time.
I don't know if he's the only one we'll find out from him,
but in 1993 he had an article in Spin magazine.
That was the first one that I read that addressed the whole age thing and that
was right after my first aids.
You get anybody on the entire science on the other side,
on the phone?
No,
but you know what,
we'll,
we'll eventually.
It was hard getting him in here in the first place.
I didn't bring him in here for a debate,
you know,
so we kind of to the tricky thing when people said,
why don't you go after people when they were to show you something stupid first
of all,
because I don't want to be mean.
And second of all,
I want them to express themselves to the fullest extent of their possibilities.
I don't,
I don't want to suppress.
you know,
I may disagree with someone on some things and we may disagree and argue about
stuff on the podcast,
but in order to find out what someone really believes about something,
sometimes you have to not question it so much as just sort of probe and,
and let them keep going and people are like,
why don't you call them out on that?
I'm like,
you know,
that's bullshit.
And like I want to hear what their logic is.
I want to hear what their thought process when I have such strong political.
Like I'll get,
I'll get heated if you start talking about how,
you know,
you can start giving me left wing solutions to like economic solutions to
things.
I get overheated and bunched up,
but if we had socialism but,
but at the same time it just helped everybody.
I went hunting and going hunting.
I had no idea that hunting with have a political effect on me politically.
Like it was very interesting.
What were you go if you,
if you.
Sometimes I have to check myself and go,
how much of this is attitude and how I've been raised to actually really
stopping and looking at fat.
You have to always check yourself because you know,
if you're a change,
what's the hunting thing that changed?
Like I just,
I just have,
I have,
I have a new found respect for,
for that aspect of regulation and strong laws that make it very clear that you
can't and not you.
You can't trust hunters to be libertarian about their hunting practices
necessarily because you get a lot of people out there in this world that a lot
of hunters are vastly.
Vast.
Majority of real hunters are very responsible,
but you get a lot of jerk offs who go out there and just want a machine gun.
And I think that the hunters,
um,
I think the anti hunting people ultimately the sentiment,
the idea behind what they're saying,
what offends them about hunting is noble.
Cause I think what they're trying to do is protect animals from ruthless people.
And I think that there are of the mind that we can get along in harmony with
nature.
And that they know that in their own personal experiences,
they've had beautiful moments that they've seen wildlife and they didn't have to
kill it.
So I think ultimately know,
like when you trap an animal and you're making a fur coat and that animal
writhing in a,
in a trap,
I wouldn't want to fucking see that.
I went to Portugal and walks to both fight.
I was,
I've never rooted for a fucking human being to die so,
so hard in my life.
They were like,
spearing this bull.
He was in pain.
They rub its eyes with a hot peppers so it can't see.
And every time they had to pick a piccadilly would stick those fucking spirits
and it's back.
The thing would jump and ride and pain.
And I was like,
can some.
I hope one of these humans fucking dies.
And this ring that I had done,
I watched these guys fucking like,
let themselves get Gordon.
There were the toughest motherfuckers on the planet that's not gone to the bull.
Didn't have a sharp horns.
And they'd let these bullets just fucking hit them and throw them over their
backs.
And they do flips in there.
There were a total bad asses,
but,
but either way,
I just didn't want to see an animal suffering aspect of human nature.
I didn't want to see a fucking a fucking a defenseless animal rive in pain.
I didn't like that shit.
No,
it's disgusting.
But you know,
so we have to then.
Then the argument is like,
okay,
well then you gotta look at the vegetarian or Vegan argument,
you know,
will there,
they're trying to be as free of this negative Karma of murdering.
Shouldn't say murder because he gets murdered was only prism as a form of
religion in some ways.
Right?
I mean it seems to be sort of.
I mean it's a philosophy,
but the,
my point is like how does,
how does one manage the animals done?
If we get to that point where no one's eating any animals,
what are you going to do?
You're going to castrate them.
What are you going to do about the deer and the wild,
what are you going to do?
We're going to have a real issue and that's something that no one needs to mean.
We have to grow as much animal protein first of all,
right.
You,
it doesn't matter.
What are you going to do with the feed?
I don't think you'd be able to feed as many people.
So would you just let the cows starve to death and cows go extinct?
Or would you manage a population of them that you never bred?
Are you suppose you'd stopped breathing when she let them go wild.
And if you did,
they wouldn't have any natural predators.
They did the big question that like,
like fucking awesome.
Uh,
Ray Kurzweil says,
listen,
we're very,
very soon you're going to be,
we're going to be cloning a meat that has no animal suffering.
We're going to be cloning,
meet with no central nervous system.
Kind of taste like shit.
Well,
no,
because we can clone the best tasting meat in the world if you've got in a
factory.
So I'm just saying the future is going to be a far a meat farm.
You ever see like salmon that you buy that hasn't been dyed pink.
Really?
See what those.
Yes.
Weak ass prison bitch salmon.
Yeah.
But what what I'm saying is that at the end of the day,
I think technology is going to give you the greatest tasting,
everything without animal suffering and meat's going to be just like anything
else.
It's going to be you're gonna buy a meat ball that was grown in some fucking
farm.
Wonder if it's possible to get the subtle nuances of legere good grass fed
steak.
I one,
if you can get that or for wonder if it's going to be like sorta like grape gum
where it's not really grape gum,
but you call it grape gum flavors.
Grape.
Oh,
I love group.
It doesn't say anything.
That's why I like game meat so much.
You can't compete with that fucking game.
Not Game Me.
Brian Endgame.
I'm like grape soda?
There's grape soda.
Taste anything like a grape?
No,
not at all.
It's like the color,
maybe Welch's grape juice.
It's about us.
That's real grape juice.
They're like sweet.
But yeah,
but like think about like,
what's the difference between like grape Hubba,
bubba bubble gum and like an actual great.
But how do you even know that that's a great.
You know,
it's a great because you've accepted this as the substitute grape flavor,
even though it's not nothing great blank about it.
You call it.
That's great flavor.
You know,
that's what stakes going to be like.
We're going to get used to that.
We're going to use this artificial non,
you know,
non biological or they'll be able to figure out a way to put all those nuances
and when they do the first people that either they're going to get cancer the
like immediately
I wonder.
It seems like how long can you keep tricking the system?
Well,
the only way we're going to feed as many people as we do with as we,
as we get into nine,
10 billion people in the century is with genetically modified foods.
You're not doing any other 10 billion.
You have to figure out a way to make rice more nutritious.
That's what golden rice product,
that golden rice project is all about.
I guess getting more vitamin a into rice and,
and,
and making it way more nutritious to make sure that more people breed.
So we have even more people.
Well,
that's very important,
isn't the most important thing to figure out how to make these places less poor,
you know,
like when you look at all the poverty in the world and all of these people that
are in these incredibly over populated areas like how does one ever managed the
human animal,
the human race from the ground up,
the lowest form growing far more food per hectare than we ever have,
right?
With technology and making it more nutrient dense.
So the idea is like if you create staples of crops like rice,
that is,
that is as nutritious as a root vegetable,
like a sweet potato.
So your,
your thing is to take these people that live in these poor places and make them
farmers.
No,
actually you'll need less farmers and you'll need less pesticides because what
you'll do is you're genetically modified these foods too and they're already
doing this to resist a,
the need for artificial pesticides because they have built in resistance to the
pests that are indigenous to that area.
And that's what.
That's what this is all about.
Genetically modified foods gets such a bad rap,
but that's the future.
We're not gonna feed people without it really.
Do you think that the thing with a,
with taking these genetically modified foods and copywriting them and making
sure that people have that,
you know,
making sure the seeds can't grow suicide's not the answer to that.
When it starts becoming a commodity,
it gets a little weird.
You know?
It has been.
I think it's just becoming more complicated.
Trademark life.
It's a really interesting question though because like you're right if you,
if you.
But if you spend a lot of time in a laboratory and you create a,
the most nutritious rice kernel in the world that people can live on just rice.
Well then if that was all your hard work,
I guess you should own the rights to the seed.
Right?
Well maybe you should just get a cut forever.
Yeah,
because because otherwise people wouldn't be the incentive to develop that is
not only just a humanitarian one,
but it's also a profit motive.
Senator Incentive.
That's why you've put billions of dollars into research to recoup it.
Cross pollination and shit like that,
like the issues that they deal with with farmers living in nearby communities
that don't have to.
I them.
I'd say it's an issue becoming.
I don't know how you fight the inevitable rise of technology though.
You and I talk about it all the time.
You can.
I,
I just don't think that we're going to,
like I said,
I think that the crops have continued.
Farmers from the beginning of time have done everything they can to make their
particular crop more nutritious,
more calorie rich,
more dense,
more energy efficient and also lasts longer last longer and need less water.
Need less taste the sides all that.
Well,
yeah.
I mean whatever we can,
whatever.
It doesn't matter.
They just trying to engineer and durability and who knows like as far as like
the vitamin content of one of those payless tomatoes at the marketplace.
So like you,
you know,
the are people in the marketplace that want a tomato that's going to taste good
as well.
So there's an incentive to create a good tasting tomato.
You know?
Have you ever really had a real tomato though?
Like a jersey.
They so good.
That's why it's a fruit.
Like when you went to La and you see the fruits that are grown in manure than
tomatoes.
Forget it.
That's why I eat organically because I'm such a great.
Even organically.
I mean the only thing that comes closest,
like heirloom tomatoes,
you know what they say the best lamb is,
you know where it comes from?
Where Iraq.
Really?
Yeah.
Iraq,
it they say is the sweetest tasting land because they eat a certain kind of
grass there and it's,
you know,
it's Mesopotamia.
They've been eaten goat and land there from the beginning of time.
You know?
It's supposed to be insanely good.
Yak Really?
Supposed to be delicious too.
Fattening.
I bet it apparently.
What Ma,
what they eat to make it taste so good.
Some moss that grows way the fuck up there that you can't even grow down here,
so you can't make them in a farm.
You can't like make a yak farm and have them eat this shit.
Dirty animal,
man.
They can go problem.
They don't need sleeping bags.
It's supposed to be delicious.
Wow.
Yak,
Yak.
You'll eat the shit out of a Yak.
I will.
I'll jerk it too.
I was watching Rinella show.
They went hunting for,
I think it's called a tarp.
Some some fucking crazy looking at wookie animal or something or some horn
wookie.
Goat.
Demon thing in New Zealand.
It was nuts.
They were up in the middle of this fucking like they have to cross this glacial
river.
We're a though the runoff from the glacier.
They had to shot an animal and the other side so they had to cross it like what
we did is like a really safe hunt for that guy.
Like he,
he,
he does some wild shit.
Man Rinella.
Stabbing pigs.
Ed had a episode,
the same place in New Zealand where they hold the pigs down with a dog and then
they stab it with a knife to kill it.
Do you want to know what might the history on my phone,
my mobile phone as you want.
You want to to the district.
This is so fucking ridiculous.
It starts with ostrich.
Chuck Taylors,
Rockstar,
big white Dick,
muscular perfection.
Ice Cube,
seven,
eight.
Area Code Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Cool hats,
Atlanta to Fort Lauderdale,
508 area code,
toe walkers,
billings,
Montana,
couches,
slam dunk.
Hard workouts.
Andy cause l comedian.
I want to know who he was.
I heard his name.
Cool.
T shirt design and best breakfast in Fort Lauderdale.
Yeah,
no.
If you were working as a ceo of an important company and they found that the big
white Dick,
they'd be like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck is this?
But I wanted to send a big white Dick to a friend of mine.
I was like,
hope you're having a great day.
And I just said that because I'm fucking.
I'm 12.
You can't have that kind of sense of humor if you work in corporate America.
No,
that's the thing to poisons.
Most people,
men suppression,
daily suppression all day having to fit a mold,
work in some fucking stupid office somewhere that's got to be life sapping.
I would agree.
The idea that one of the problems with government is that there's no passion in
most levels of government.
They're just jobs,
you know,
and the real problem with jobs as people want to get them and they want that
money and they want to keep them and they never say,
you know what?
This job is just not really necessary and that the way to best serve the
American people would be to fucking get rid of this job,
but this is what I need.
It becomes a personal issue that sort of gets in the way of the greater good of
what you're trying to achieve.
You're not getting rid of a foot when you.
That's the problem with passing a law.
You're going to get a lot of vested interests around that law.
You're not getting rid of that law because then people lose their jobs.
Okay,
so that's the other thing.
Remember when you pass a law,
cottage industry grows up around it.
That's why.
That's why Washington never gets rid of.
Once they pass a law,
like the,
the anti marijuana laws you get,
you make illegal and you're going to have a lot of people out of a job.
So yeah,
there's a lot of money behind trying to marijuana illegal and there was
something that I retweeted,
I think yesterday that was listing all the different people that are involved in
working hard to keep marijuana illegal.
It's so annoying.
Read that Shit.
It just just makes you nuts.
God.
Check this out.
There's already been a voter machines going crazy.
Look at this video.
It's switching people's votes from Obama to seeing that switches it.
I'm not surprised that they,
you know,
they never fixed that shit.
These fucking Republicans on all these voting machines,
they,
they showed in that hacking democracy documentary that you could fix them so
that they could change the vote.
That's where it's ridiculous.
Fucking scan.
This isn't a real life we're living.
It's all fake.
We're living in a goddamn simulation.
Problem is you've got to kind of care and you got to be informed.
Otherwise sources will take your freedom away from it.
If they're already taking it with differences them.
You got to figure out a way to fight back,
you know?
Have you seen these this way?
Have you seen the,
the Chinese practice of eating eggs boiled in the urine of young boys?
Sure.
Haven't.
I sure haven't seen that.
But please google that.
Chinese people eat eggs boiled in the urine of Virgin Boys.
No,
he didn't look at this yesterday.
I found that someone tweeted this out,
my twitter timeline,
pocus horseshoe.
If you look at my twitter timeline,
they,
uh,
they have young boys,
they have them pee and then they boil eggs in this young boy p and a.
They eat it all day.
They say it keeps them healthy and it's great for the skin.
It's like a super,
like common,
delicate shrink.
The actual urine.
No,
they eat the eggs after it's been boiled and little kid pis,
but it has to be like virgin boys I guess once to start fucking becomes
problematic.
Do they boiled their hard,
boil it and they actually crack the egg shell.
So the urine seeps into the egg itself.
Not just heats it up from the outside,
seeps in and simmers for hours and hours and piss would say post human beings 22
hours ago.
Humans are dumb.
Hey,
do you have a guy?
You know,
I retweeted it.
A dude named Adrian frigidaire refrigerator over there.
Don't get it.
We're going to wrap this up soon and grabbed me one to um,
I don't think there's anything in there.
Dude.
There's nothing in your fridge up.
Mountain dew,
whatever it is in Cannes.
We should stop at Costco,
which is fucking stock this place full.
Want to go to Cosco letter?
I do all the time.
It just goes really fast.
Yeah,
but because you bring in slots in here and they get thirsty sucking cock.
So it's what it is.
That's what I heard.
So true.
I'm not finding this because you're retarded.
Come on dude.
Sitting there from.
I told you,
retweet.
Retweet from a dude named Adrian a fifth of November.
I got 24 hours ago now.
Yeah.
What I love about you is that you have used your influence for nothing,
but I'm sorry.
It's Wilford Lee.
That's the guy's name.
Sorry.
Wilford Lee is the guy tweeted it to me on November fifth.
No,
it was 22 hours ago.
I was looking at something else.
Alright,
here we go.
You see it?
Yeah.
Pull this up.
This is going to be so ridiculous.
So what we're saying,
where were you thinking before?
I love that you have,
as your influence has grown,
you've,
you've done nothing but take care of your friends and people around you and
trying to make the world a better place.
Well,
you know what?
That world a better place thing I'd done or know about that.
Well,
no,
you try to look at that.
Oh,
there we go and boil
urine of young boys.
Preferably those below the age of 10.
Hence the name virgin boy eggs,
popular springtime snacking touted for its health benefits.
We have to be very careful about going to war with these people.
It's like somebody came up with a gimmick to sell eggs and,
and uh,
it's just a smart entrepreneur.
Some guy in the corner 100,000 years ago,
teaching them what's.
It takes a full day to prepare the snacks,
starting off with collecting urine from boys' toilets.
Then the extra soaked and boiled in pots of urine after which the shells are
cracked and the extra simmered in the same urine for hours.
Those who snack on the exit,
they helped decrease body heat and promote better blood circulation.
That can make one feel reinvigorated.
No.
Well my God,
I already do this by eating.
These eggs will not have any pain or waist legs and joints.
Also you'll have more energy when you do work on what is the folks in Don young
are convinced.
What would you like eating these people like it because they have this tradition
in Dong Yang.
Did these eggs and nourishment for our health and that it would help prevent
things like getting a code.
I don't believe in this at all.
I don't eat.
Medical experts have mixed reviews about the health benefits and some worn of
sanitary issues in this unique delicacy
in the doctor world.
Declaring the virgin boy x as an intangible cultural heritage.
Huh?
You know what's so funny?
This is probably a huge troll.
Like somebody put that on your message board.
Like what if it's just like the onion for China.
It could be,
yeah,
they could have just had a picture of simmering eggs and had a picture of the
stalls and pretended they pitched this.
Go to Venice,
California right now and find a group of people that are boiling eggs and
fucking young boy piss you think so.
Our old man piss because somebody came up with this idea.
Yeah.
I think we've always boiled shit and piss
and at the same reason,
you know,
you people would eat like,
I don't like it.
They like why virgins are so prized as your Chinese people do a lot of freaky
shit with eggs.
Like one of the things I'm fearful or 100 year old eggs.
Eggs.
Yeah.
Baloo guys.
It's um,
an egg that's like fermented and black and it looks like Jelly.
Yeah.
We used to serve them to people on fear factor.
Like it's disgusting,
but they were like a real delicacy in Chinese.
When I was 14 years old,
back when China was comments,
I went to the mainland,
I spoke two weeks.
Their family.
When you look at the bus,
all you saw,
I looked,
turned around.
I saw back then most people in blue uniforms on bicycles,
Beijing was just one ballou.
See,
oh,
it was just a communist country.
Everybody wore the exact same blue outfit.
I wore a rode bicycles.
Was it freaky?
It was the freakiest thing I've ever seen in my life.
No advertisements.
Think about that.
No advertising,
no billboards,
no advertisements.
And Russia was the same way.
I went to Russia when it was communist.
There was no,
no advertising.
So you go and you go,
why is everything so gray?
Well,
there's no advertising.
There is no,
there is no color.
So you don't have people saying by this that you weren't allowed to do that.
Everything was run by the state.
Uh,
restaurants were these huge communal,
sort of a huge communal affairs.
So when you go to a restaurant,
do you have to pay anything?
Like how that were?
Very,
very little.
Everybody pays the same.
Right?
But when you pay like one beer,
that was one national beer,
there was one,
you know,
uh,
it was,
everything was so uniform.
I went to the pecan pagodas.
I went to the,
you know the,
there are very few Buddhist shrines that were really survived the communist
revolution.
Have you been back since?
No,
no.
I mean chat Beijing now is completely different,
but I went.
I was in Russia in 1985
in China.
China has more billionaires than anywhere else in the world.
They buy buicks.
Yeah.
They really liked buicks and yet they still have a very various oppressive
government,
but they,
the Chinese have always.
The one thing that's that really is really unique to China is that a huge area
of land speaks one language,
mandarin,
Chinese and that there's almost no other example like that in the world.
However,
that's because the Yangtze and the Yellow River,
we're able to bring ideas and commerce and language to all different parts of
China and so China became this uniform powerhouses result of that.
What's more fascinating to me is how they all look Chinese.
That's the credit.
That's the other thing that you want to talk about,
like a really fast area,
a credible size place,
and they all share a very similar gene pool.
I mean at least visually cause of the anxiety and Yellow River,
there was so much trade knew you were able to get in.
We were able to.
Food production,
domestication of animals created huge city centers and it concentrated a great
deal of people in one area.
I love how when you see northern Russia and Siberia,
it gets really Chinese looking.
While I was in.
I was focused on and if you talk to people from Pakistan and Kyrgyzstan,
which are the areas that kind of like,
right.
We're part of Russia used to be.
They're all,
they're all,
they look very,
very high cheekbones,
very Asian.
They look more Mongol.
They're tall,
usually strong looking,
you know,
broad people with these high cheekbones.
If you see something like that,
doesn't it kind of like put you in touch with history?
Like you start thinking about like the gang is gone,
Eric yourself out.
If you really want to freak out and you want to see specimens of human beings,
go to the fucking Sudan,
go to Kenya and go take a look at the Maasai warriors.
Just go take a look.
If you want to know where the fuck guys like Scottie Pippen and Michael Jordan
come from,
I don't care.
To me it says they are the,
they are these beautiful,
these fucking six foot seven,
seven foot people in the span.
These,
these,
they live a nomadic lifestyle.
Seven feet,
no problem.
Athletic is all fucking get out wide and big head's the size of basketballs.
You're like,
where the fuck did you come from?
It is a different gene pool.
And how did that one gene pool rise?
How did the,
how did the pygmies in the Congo arise?
You know,
there,
there are a lot of theories on the biology of why people do it,
but a lot of it had to do with um,
like how isolated that gene pool was at.
For example,
Paul Pan Asian people,
very isolated for a long period of time.
Uh,
you know,
Hawaii and,
and,
and especially Tonga and Samoa,
I mean,
up until I think it was the late 17,
early 18 hundreds,
they'd never been contacted by white people.
You know what's interesting about islands is that animals tend to dwarf on
islands,
but lizards tend to grow towards giant.
So yeah,
that's why the Komodo dragons became like enormous lizard.
They were isolated to the Komodo islands,
but like pygmy elephants and shit like that,
or they.
Yeah,
in the sense that,
yeah,
the I'm not enough.
The hobbit people,
those,
a Homo Floresiensis,
those little tiny human beings that lived alongside people.
That's also like an episode of like an island.
Dwarfism.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I wonder though why,
why was it a form of natural selection where they grow so tall?
People like me because Sudans ridiculous fight off lines and shit and the big
ones survived.
And the Masai Mara are fucking tall athletic that the Masa just broke the
fucking half mile record in the Olympics this year.
World record ran like fucking destroyed.
Everybody.
Well that guy,
you know,
comparing them.
That's the conversation we were having earlier with like some fucking fat Doughy
Guy,
Gabriel Iglesias guy and you know,
like physically if they're going to get an MMA fight,
one of them is cheating already.
I got a shitty.
I got,
I didn't win the genetic lottery and I'm okay to fail.
I didn't fail either.
I'm all right,
but when I look at fucking.
Yeah,
I got to 70.
You look at these fucking Simone's with their back of their arms,
those big elbows and their knees.
Mark Hunt,
looking legs,
command
five minutes the.
Have you ever seen relentless enemies?
No.
It's a documentary on this one area of Africa.
We're a 100 years,
no relentless enemy and this the lines,
the giant lines.
There's an area where the river changed course 100 years ago and it's stranded
all these lions and water buffalo in this one area,
and because the lines don't have any other way other than water buffalo,
pull that up Brian.
Just pull up a video will end with this.
Blow your fucking socks off.
They become hoke sized lines.
The female lions are as large as regular mail,
500 pound.
They're enormous muscular,
unbelievably muscular because all they eat is water buffalo.
These giant fucking buffaloes that they need like seven or eight of them to take
on,
so they jump on their back and one of them goes underneath and they try to drag
this thing down.
The water buffaloes to search for a relentless enemies lion versus water
buffalo.
It's fucking incredible.
And they look like CGI lions.
They looked like the hulk,
like they have giant muscles.
I can't believe you don't know about this.
No.
How do I not know about this?
You're gonna Jack off to this night is going to end your night.
Do you?
Have you seen the eye of the sparrow,
the bad lip sinking of the presidential debate?
What does that.
This.
You can't.
You have to.
We have to watch that before you take off.
The
higher the speed,
you do relentless enemy's relentless.
Relentless enemies.
Did you just write whether Buffalo,
what the fuck did you?
Oh,
it's so hard to see.
It's so blurry.
Why does it?
They,
they.
They can't make one of those things.
It looks like a monitor.
What'd you say about water?
Buffalo?
Just relentless enemies.
That's it.
Click on that.
These fucking things.
You got wait till you see what they look like.
I think this is the trailer for the movie.
What happened?
Fucking windows.
That's cool.
That's good.
Good resolution.
They bribed me to buy a flat screen TV.
We get this water.
Buffalo Jesus Christ.
Imagine having to eat that thing.
That's all you can eat and wait till you sweat these fucking lions.
Dude,
is this over a course of 100 years,
so it's really changing the way they look about how animals and tapped.
Okay.
These things.
That's death.
Look at the muscles on the way to use the muscles in the fucking females,
man mean you never seen anything like that.
They're swimming out to get this water buffalo.
They can't
look at that.
All predators pray.
Jeremy Irons.
We'll get the size of these fucking lines.
That's a smaller one.
Shit.
Oh my God.
This.
Kiss me.
What are you doing,
Brian?
Subtler bitch.
Look at how they have to fight these things.
There's several.
Several
different prides on this island and not all of them are oversized.
It's interesting.
If we saw that some of them are regular sized.
Can I see that relentless enemies get it on Netflix.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it's available on Amazon.
Go Buy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and buy it from there.
And Brian makes money.
We use
quickly so I can show Joe just sparrow.
Podcast is almost over time.
We turn into a pumpkin and two minutes,
two seconds.
Come see me at helium Gemelli.
Go see him or come see me and joey ideas in San Diego at the elbow with theater.
Boom.
Hold on.
Saturday night.
This Saturday night.
Oh Man,
I'm in fucking dead punch.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you're on the east coast.
Come see me and helium and I'll tell you all about joe wrote.
I got loose in San Francisco,
knocked the Dixon to the dirt and Seattle spirit.
Eyes of the sparrow.
Can I have the sparrow?
Seattle.
So fun that Seattle's great.
So you just didn't see how I just did.
The more smart people,
they get it and love it.
I love it.
It's just dreary as fuck
up there,
but they enjoy the shit out of a show.
So dreary though.
Sos Canada.
But if they,
they're the greatest audiences.
Vancouver's not as dreary scooper and can't wait.
What are you doing in Vancouver?
You do theaters.
I love Vancouver.
What are you going to do?
Comedy Mix.
I'm going to do comedy and that place is great.
Duncan trussell just sold that out.
We tweeted about it and he sold it out in one day so that the whole weekend.
It's great.
What are we watching here?
No,
no,
no.
What do you.
Don't let him Google on its own.
You've got to tell him.
What the fuck are you going to see a castle sparrow.
Bad.
Bad lip sinking that lives there.
They're right there.
The second one,
watch this.
Wash that say,
this is so fucking funny.
We were watching this.
This is.
This is the president's debate,
and they they,
they redubbed their voices because they walked their mouths and they could be
saying something else.
Watch this.
This is so wild
on.
This is the one.
No,
the hot tub.
It's cool now poisoning.
I know,
right?
I know.
Sing me some harmonies.
It's a small picture in a shop somewhere and I know who it is.
It's Mormon,
judy and cow people.
Little pitchy but good stuff.
Governor Romney's black.
I think black can be judged.
How do I do this?
Dude?
I don't have a jet ski.
Not the kind you're talking about.
Plus everyone can see that I'm not black.
You have to enjoy the civic stuff.
These guys to laugh at this.
I mean,
I do want you to support me and be my man.
That's beautiful.
I know he's black.
Ahmed,
how did you know about who done it in the lounge?
Didn't know.
Well,
you didn't study clapping for the mad cow until someone sold him.
Who is that creepy old
debates?
Boy Stuff.
That dude's the sickest.
We hate him because he had eggs for a bath.
I'm gonna throw up tonight,
but if you throw up and it's as a jealous on that,
you have to see this stupid.
Governor Romney won't do that.
Okay.
Audio is not doing.
This.
Just got me thinking.
I see a purple idiot speaks German with a big spunky Irish labradoodle puppy.
Oh,
he got me and I want you to feel bad because I've got funny radiation coming up.
I'm like,
come on,
I'm not a robot.
Okay.
I wish I could go higher and you could rotate my arm and send me wishing into
space.
Hear me on that
shot is so fucking cool.
Right off.
17.
Stupid.
You got to see it firsthand.
When is it over folks?
Who the fuck is the price?
This is election day.
Two thousand 12.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Vote a month before the apocalypse.
Right now.
Whoa.
You Ready?
This what?
I'm
Mitt Romney's in the lead right now.
He has 152 electoral votes to 23 for Obama.
Obama has a 48 percent and he has 50 percent.
Wow.
If this guy wins,
this is going to be really strange.
I'm more concerned about the condom Moore's law.
The common law for a porn stars now.
Well,
we're just going to have to buy or download our porn from like Russia.
Yeah,
sharing.
That's just what it is,
man.
Snow.
Well,
there's no way.
People were just going to watch people fuck with condoms on.
They tried that for awhile.
Remember that didn't work.
You ever,
you ever clip,
clicked on a link and you see like a condom and you get upset.
You watched porn and the guys were in a car I can't beat on the podcast is
overlays to gentlemen.
Go fuck yourselves,
but do it.
Do it kindly and gently.
Go see Brian Cowen this weekend at helium,
helium in Philadelphia.
Google it,
bitch.
I hate.
Go to death squad dot TV.
Goodbye yourself.
Kittycat tee shirt,
Ohio.
This we support the squad
Ohio along with Tony Hinchcliffe and Brian Redmond.
Can Somebody please tweet me?
Fucking just tweet me at Bryan County and give me an idea for a man thoughts tee
shirt,
please don't beg for ideas.
You son of a bitch.
Hire somebody.
Hiring artists.
Got goddammit tomorrow night,
tomorrow night.
Ice House comedy club.
You coming down,
you're gonna.
Be able to make it possible to 10:30.
Show
what show you got to do and the angry inch?
No.
Is it good?
It's the best thing I've ever seen.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
if you don't want to do that,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you want to come down to the ice house will be.
I want to come get your freak on getting our warmup on getting fired up for this
weekend.
Me and mad flavor will be A.
I don't know if Duncan is gonna.
Be able to make it this weekend,
but I know he's coming.
My rarest common.
Can Ian come is he ain't got a Gig tomorrow night.
Tomorrow.
I'll ask and find them.
Find out a little esther as well.
A little less was coming and Brian Redmans comment to can do.
She can't do it.
What happened?
She got more important.
Shit happened.
Oh wait,
no.
She can do it no matter what the fuck,
man.
You're fucking with people's emotions,
dude.
All right.
This podcast is officially over.
We will see you tomorrow at 2:00 PM with Dr Peter Duesberg and Brian Cowen and
we'll talk about aids,
the good aids.
Goodnight everybody.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and go fuck yourself.